독도마뱀이라는 게 있어요 1년에 식사를 한 4번 한대요
엄청 큰 놈을 먹은 다음에 천천히 소화 흡수 시키는 거예요
시간이 긴 지혈피원 우리 찾으면 대박이다 이런 생각을 계속하고 있었는데
얘는 뭔가 소화 흡수 시간이 너무 길잖아요
그래가지고 독도마뱀의 지혈피원을 이제 추출해가지고 약으로 써본 거예요
아 그럼 제꺼야?
독도마뱀 처음 시작은
내꺼지롱 메롱 이렇게
오늘 우창윤 선생님 오랜만에 또 모셨고요
반갑습니다
점심을 또 안 드셨다길래 저도 마침 안 먹었거든요
배고파요
그래서 이거 빨리 얼른 드시죠
오늘 좀 헤비한 거 먹을 줄 알고 기대하고 왔는데 생각보다 맛있는 거였어요
쌤이 하도 건강 건강하셔가지고 이렇게 준비를 했어요 샐러드로
아 훌륭합니다
네
네 이렇게 닭가슴살 한 덩어리에다가 단백질 부족할까 봐 계란까지 해가지고
이 정도 분량으로 먹으면 딱 적당한 거예요? 한 끼로?
아니면 좀 더 먹어야 돼요?
좀 부족하죠
부족한 편이구나
성인 남성은 좀 부족하죠
그럼 이렇게 먹으면 무조건 빠질 수밖에 없네요
빠지는데
이제 배고파서
배고픔을 참아야 되니까 단백질 양을 좀 늘려서 포만감을 좀 더 주거나
사과나 뭐 키위 같은 거 좀 먹어서 포만감을 좀 주거나
여기에 초코파이 하나 곁들이면 어때요?
그러면 이제 별로죠
확 별로가 돼?
확 별로가 되죠
다 여기까지 잘 쌓아놨다가
아니 근데 뭐 초코파이만 먹는 것보다 훨씬 낫죠
할당반도 적고 괜찮은데 초코파이 먹으면 좀 걸으면 돼요
그럼 일반적인 백반 먹는 거랑 이거에다가 초코파이 추가하는 거랑
백반도 반찬이 뭐냐에 따라 너무 다른데
백반 그냥 막 달고 짜고 일반적인 식당 백반
그냥 제육
차라리 백반이 나을 것 같긴 해요
아 초코파이 하나 추가하는 거고요?
초코파이 먹고 싶으면 이게 먹는 게 습관돼서 확실히
약간 달라요
초코파이 먹고 싶어 하는 거랑
이따도 이야기 나오겠지만
이 밥을 먹고 싶어 하는 거랑 달라요
이거 배부르다고 담배 안 피우고 싶어요?
배부르다고 술 안 마시고 싶어요?
아 마시고 싶어요
그쵸 비슷해요
약간 식구땡 하고 싶은 말이랑 비슷할 수 있어요
아
그게 습관되면
저는 보통 제육도 먹고 초코파이 세 개 먹어요
봐봐 어차피 배고파서 먹는 게 아니니까
근데 제가 사실 요즘에 좀 말라진 편이에요
배가 이렇게 나왔는데
이 배도 들어간 편이에요 지금
뭐 했어요?
최근에 너무 동그래져가지고
배가?
배도 그리고 얼굴도 동그래지고
역대급이었어요
체중도 많이 늘었어요?
체중을 재봤는데
신기록 85kg까지 쪘어요
제가 원래 78kg에서 80kg까지 왔다 갔다 했거든요
85kg까지 가서 동글동글해져가지고
아내가 아
계속 뭐라고 하는 거예요
근데 나는 몰랐지
계속 내가 날 보면 모르잖아
그쵸 그쵸
근데 보는 사람마다 나보고
수제비가 왜 이렇게 많이 붙었냐
그리고 내가 언제 깨달았냐면
외부 촬영을 하고 찍은 걸 봤는데
오 진짜 동글동글한 거야
그러게 침착맨님은 그래도 약간 라인 나쁘지 않았었는데
내가 그냥 거울을 볼 때는 몰랐어요
수제비 냄새인데
근데 이제 옆모습을 볼 수 있잖아요
그래서 이제 동글동글해진 거야
그래서 전에는 한 턱살 정도만 나왔다고 치면
이제는 다 전체적으로 동글동글해져서
한 열흘 전부터 롤 한 판 안 한다고 생각하고
딱 30분만 뛰자
오 훌륭하다
그리고 간식을 먹지 말자
오 그것도 훌륭하다
먹긴 먹었어요
뿌셔 뿌셔 최근에
완벽할 수 없어요?
근데 웬만하면 의식해서 먹지 말자
그거 두 개를 했거든요
한 1kg 빠졌어요
딱 좋다
근데 이제 그렇게 하면 내장 지방 먼저 빠질 거예요 형은
그래서 배가 좀 들어갔나
근데 들어가도 인정돼
사실 오늘 할 게 있습니다
뭐냐면 요즘 다이어트 약으로 각광받는 마훈자로
위곱이 거의 그냥 신약이라고
신이 내린 약이라고 하는 얘기를 많이 해요 사람들이
아 이거 진짜 완전 치트키다
이거 먹으면 주변은 다 빠졌다
근데 이게 과연
일단 알고 좀 먹어야 되는데
제 주변에 쌤이 그냥 내과잖아요
내분비 완전 딱이잖아요
내분비 내과죠
저희가 그 지혈표는 사는 과예요 원래
그래서 좀 이걸 좀 자세히 알고 싶어서
이게 사실 마훈자로나 위곱이 다 관심 많고
나도 한번 해볼까 라는 생각도 많이 하시는데
이게 정확하게 부작용이 뭐고
효과는 뭐고 그런 걸 좀 알고 싶잖아요
그래서 쌤한테 오늘 한번 듣는 시간 가져보고 싶습니다
충분히 좀 저희 좀 궁금증이 해결될까요?
아 뭐 저 궁금한 거 제가 다 이야기하고 있어요
다 이야기 드릴 수 있고
사실 저 이거 관련된 강의를 의사 상대로 되게 많이 해요
워낙에 내분비 쪽 의사가 많지 않기도 하고
이제 뭐 다른 과 쌤들도 많이 처방하다 보니까
관련된 강의를 하도 많이 해가지고
뭐 궁금한 것들 좀 이야기 드리고
처음에는 좀 재미 흥미 위주로 이야기 드릴게요
일단 여러분 우리가 지금 얼마나 좋은 세상에 사는지 알려면은
우리의 그 조상님들은 어떤 약을 먹고 다이어트 했는지 알아야 돼요
그거 알아야 아 이게 진짜
이게 아까 형이 말했던 신약 신이 만든 약이구나
이 느낌이 와요
일단 그렇게 멀리도 안 갑니다
19세기 20세기 초 제가 좀 재미있는 것들만 좀 몇 개 골라왔거든요
실제 있었던 건데요
아 진짜 먹고 안 죽으면 살이 빠지는 비소약
진짜 비소를 먹었어요
원래 비소가 이게 좀 바르기만 해도 얼굴이 창백해지거든요
어 얼굴도 창백해지고 살도 빠지네
이게 지금 에스테틱이 어떻게 보여요
살 빠지고 얼굴도 하얘지고 피부 좋아보이고
그래서 비소를 바르고 먹고 이거를 되게 많이 했어요
그럼 요즘에 하는 그런 거 비소로 하는 건 아니에요?
아니죠 지금은 레이저로 하는 거예요
이제는 흔히 말하는 뭐 rf다 하이프다 초음파나 이런 레이저 같은
그게 몸을 괴롭히는 거예요?
아니요 그거는 괴롭힌다기보다 콜라겐을 좀 신생시켜 주거나
콜라겐을 좀 이렇게 축축시켜 주는 좀 그런 것들 재생시켜 주거나
비소를 먹으면은 옛날에는 살이 빠져서 소량 복용하게 됐다
이거 하면은 당연히 많이 먹으면 죽겠죠
그런데 조금씩 먹어도 죽어요 중독돼 가지고
실제로 이제 뭐 빈혈이나 뭐 암이나 이런 걸로 사람들이 많이 죽었는데
꽤 오래 썼고 여기 또 닥터제미스 막 적어져 있죠
병원에서 의사들이 팔았어요 비소를
근데 이게 살이 얼마나 잘 빠졌겠어요
살이 잘 빠졌겠죠?
그리고 또 재미있었던 거 나 이거 진짜인가 싶었는데
씻기만 하고 뱉으면 살이 빠진다
그럴싸해요?
엄청난 건데 사실 대단한 건데
씻기만 하고 뱉으면 살이 빠진다
20세기 초에 풀린 척 시식단
근데 이 사람이 음식을 씹지 않는 사람은 자연의 벌을 받을 것이다
막 이런 말을 하면서 몇 번 씹었나 봤거든요 횟수를 막 셌대요
이게 여러분이 생각하는 뭐 20, 30번이 아니에요
700번 막 이렇게
그러면은 내가 삼키지 않아도 700번 씹으면 침이 나오잖아요
그러면은 이 침 때문에 영양소랑 같이 넘어가는 게 있어
근데 700번 씹었는데 입에 남아있는 게 있잖아요
그럼 뱉자는 거야
그럼 어떻게 이겨내? 진짜 독한 사람이다
독하면 살은 빠졌겠죠 이게 뭐 식사가 되겠어요?
그래서 이 사람이 꽤 인기가 그때 많았고
막 유명 인사들도 이 사람을 막 좋아하고 추종자들도 있었고
이 사람 같이 식사하잖아요?
그러면은 본대요 몇 번 씹는지
너 침 참으면 너 아직 200번밖에 안 씹었는데 뭐 삼켜?
뒤질래?
네
그레잇 마티케이터
그리고 매일을 하나 가지고 다닐 것 같은 얼굴이에요
너 200번 씹었어?
자연의 벌을 받을 것이다 이 벌을 내가 주는 거겠죠
여하튼 뭐 이런 다이어트였어 옛날에는 많이 씹자
1900년도 초에는 이것도 있었어요
촌충 다이어트 이거 광고되기도 했다고 해요
촌충이 이거 진짜 9미터까지 자라는 기생충이거든요
근데 이론이 너무 팬시해 그 당시에는
촌충이 장에서 성충이 되면은 얘가 뭐 먹겠지? 9미터까지 자라는데?
그리고 심지어 막 토하고 설사해 아 그럼 살 빠지겠네
그리고 우리 이거 기생충 약도 이제 있잖아
필요할 때 내 몸에 기생충 넣었다가 살 좀 빼고
죽이자
기생충 약 먹어서 죽이면 되는 거 아니야?
생각할 수 있잖아요
근데 개뿔 개뿔 이거 막 아무 때나 다 가요
뇌로도 가고 막 눈으로도 가고 실명하고 막 뇌수막염 생기고 난리 나거든요
얘네가 그렇게 하기 싫었는데 너무 많아져서 막 여기저기 막 쑤시는 건가?
그 안에서부터 좀 날라갈 수 있어요 어렸을 때
이게 낭포상태예요?
낭포상태에서 막 날라가면은 막 이상한 데서 자랄 수가 있어요
그러면 죽어요 죽을 수도 있어요 진짜로
근데 이제 그거를 그냥 알약 형태로 해가지고 촌충 다이어트하고 그랬어요
이거 애니메이션에 SF 같은데 그런 설정이 있었어요
이미 있는 거에서 갖고 왔구나 기생충을 키워요 다이어트 하려고
아 진짜? 대단하네
근데 여기 이미 있었네요 거기서 갖고 왔네
어떻게 보면 지금 사실 위고비나 마온자른 여러분 단백질 약이거든요? 호르몬?
근데 이거는 생명체의 약 그 당시에 그 바이오 약이었던 거죠
근데 뭐 당연히 이거 하면 죽습니다
근데 이거 부작용만 아니면은 괜찮은 거 아니에요?
약간 혹 같잖아요 근데 그때는 이걸 잘 몰랐어요
막 뇌나 눈으로 간다고 잘 몰랐으니까 그때는
그리고 막 이런 거 갑상선 기능 항진증이 되면 살이 빠진다
딱 1900년대쯤 이제 1890년대 이때쯤에 호르몬들이 막 나오기 시작해요
호르몬들이 나오기 시작하는데 이제 그 갑상선 기능 항진증에 걸리면은 살이 빠집니다
근데 이때 아셔야 될 건 여러분들 아셔야 될 거는
근육이 무섭게 빠져요 갑상선 기능 항진이 되면은 지방도 빠지지만 근육이 진짜 무섭게 빠지는데
이게 그 갑상선 기능 항진증이 아니라 저하증 있는 환자들이 있었거든요 그때
근데 저하증 있는 환자들은 살이 쪄요 그리고 특히 막심한 사람들이 막 부으면서 살이 엄청 쪄요
막 부종 생기면서 이런 사람들한테 갑상선 호르몬 딱 주잖아요?
그러면 살이 빠지기 시작해요 당연히
그리고 당연히 이게 약간 좀 막 부스팅되는 그런 느낌이 있으니까
이거를 약으로 쓸 수 있겠다
이런 생각을 한 거죠
근데 그때 당연히 저도 이거 너무 말이 안 되는 거 같아요 좀 찾아봤어요
찾아갔더니 막 내분비 막 이런 데서 당연히 야 근데 그게 없는 사람한테 주는 거랑
좀 충분한 사람한테 추가로 주는 거랑 같냐 약 하지 마 이런 말이 당연히 있었어요
근데 그 당시에는 이거 주면은 뭐가 문제인데 이런 거에 대한 답변을 제대로 할 수 없었고
데이터가 없어서?
네 데이터가 없으니까 살을 빼고 싶어 하는 사람은 있고
이걸 또 처방하고 싶은 의사도 있고
그래서 그냥 비만인 분들한테 막 소규모로 해가지고 연구를 했던 거예요
음 예
근데 연구를 하도 이게 갑상선 호르몬 줘가지고 막 죽는 것까지 보려면 몇 년을 봐야 되는데
한 12주 보는 거죠 12주 보니까 아 내가 이거 호르몬 줘가지고 이 사람 좀 가슴 두근두근하고
대사율이 한 20%까지 막 올리는 이 정도 쓰니까
한 6주에 살 한 6kg 빠지던데 아무것도 안 했는데 살이 그냥 빠지던데 이렇게 해가지고 그냥 약으로 나온 거예요
광고도 지금 men avoided me i was too bad
예 이렇게 자극적으로 해가지고
남자들이 막 위아래로 훑어요 지금 상태를 지금 그쵸?
그니까
이때도 약간 광고는 진짜 자극적으로 했는데
그래서 약간 이때는 심지어 그 비소도 아직까지 남아있었거든요
그래서 비소
두 개 같이 먹는 경우도 있겠다
비소랑 갑상선 약이랑 이제 뭐 칼륨이랑 막 이런 것들 섞어가지고 카페인도 좀 넣고
아 하나에 그냥 뭐 그걸로 만들었구나 제품들 다 섞어서
예 예 그런 게 이때부터 좀 있었어요
몸에 안 좋겠는데 너무
아 대박 안 좋죠
안 좋은 거에다 안 좋은 거 넣고
갑상선 항진증 이렇게 만드는 약이 왜 퇴출됐냐 급사예요 급사
부정맥에 의한 급사를 많이 해요 갑자기 죽어
그래가지고 지금 대사를 항진시켜서 살을 빼는 약이 없어요 별로
뭐 카페인이다 아미노필린이다 뭐 조금 뭐 이런 게 있는 건 남아있는 약들이 있는데
걔네는 아주 미미한 거고 의미 있게 막 대사율을 15에서 20%
이건 뭐 개황권 막 쓰는 느낌이거든요 진짜
부스팅을 막 이렇게 올리는 거니까
근데 웃긴 건 드래곤볼에서 그 개황권 쓰면은 막 엄청 힘들다고 하잖아요
그냥 잠깐 힘들고 몸에 영구적인 무리가 없어서 그냥 치트키로 쓰던데?
그러니까 그거 하다가 부정매로 죽는 거예요
그래서 그게 시간 제한이 있는 게
손오공은 사이언이라서 안 죽나?
손오공도 맞으면 심장병으로 죽잖아요
아! 그거 때문이에요? 설마?
맞네 개황권 써서 그러네요
아 그런 거야? 나 그거 연결 못 했어
개황권 때문에 죽었네
아 개황권 막 엄청 남발했거든 난 10배도 했거든요
그러니까 결국은 심장 무리가 가요
사실 10배가 말이 안 되는 게 내가 힘이 100이면 1000이 되는 거예요
그냥 단순 곱하기예요 거기서
말이 안 돼
거의 대사율 10배면은 심장이 못 견뎌요
그러니까 초사이언 정도 되면은
튼튼히도 못 버틸 정도로 오버클락을 걸었구나
심장 문제를 급사해요
손오공조차도
아 그럼 심장을 했던 게 기가 막혔네 개황권 때문에 죽었네
조삼명쌤이 이걸 알고 있을까요?
조삼명쌤 특성상 생각 안 하고 있을 것 같긴 한데
모르겠어요 근데
근데 비소 있죠 비소
비소 궁금한 게 내가 만약에 되게 인자강이에요
그래서 계속 버텼어
와 비소를
그러면 그거 부작용 있어요?
암 생기죠 암
근데 암도 안 생겼어
암도 안 생겼어?
근데 살만 빠졌어 딱 진짜?
쉽지 않아요 빈혈이랑 설사 구토 점막 손상되고 막 이러니까
감염도 생기고 면역력이 떨어지니까
그러니까 이게 그냥 중금속 중독이거든요
그래서 이거를 버티긴 진짜 쉽지 않다
아무리 소량이라도 쌓이니까?
쌓이니까 문제는 쌓여 저게 처음에는 안 죽죠 조금 하니까
근데 여러분 이거 아셔야 돼요
지금도 이제 병원 중에 약을 막 믹스업 해가지고
주운 데들이 한국에 좀 있어요
이게 뭐 다른 나라도 있는지는 모르겠는데
약 한 네 다섯 개 이렇게 막 줘서 먹은 다음에
살 빠진다 이렇게 하는 병원들이 꽤 있거든요
무슨 약을 섞어요?
이제 뭐 식욕 억제제에다가 막 지방 흡수 못하는 거
뭐 탄수 흡수 못하는 거
이런 대상진 시키기 위한 약 몇 개
그리고 이뇨제 이런 것들 막 섞어요
근데 이게 1900년대부터 있었어요 여러분
그리고 보통 그게 왜 안 하냐
지금 암페타민이라는 약까지 나와가지고 1920년대
그때 이것도 하면은 살이 빠져요
식욕 억제가 확 뜨거든요
암페타민이 메스암페타민이 되면 그게 약간 히로폼 이쪽이거든요
그래서 도파리폼이 확 되게 되면서
각성 확 돼가지고 식욕이 뚝 떨어져요
불면 생기고 막 이러는 건데
아까까지는 이제 비소랑 갑산성 약 섞는 정도였잖아요
이제 이때부터는 이제 암페타민이 나오면서
암페타민 식욕을 무지하게 시키거든요
이거는 그 각성도가 너무 올라가니까
입맛이 뚝 떨어져요
그러면은 잠도 못 자죠
그리고 막 불안해져요
그러니까 이때는 이제 약들도 있어
그래서 어?
약을 쓰니까 살은 빠지는데 잠을 못 자네?
그럼 약을 줄이든지 해야 되는데
어? 그럼 수면제 쓰면 되겠다
수면제 써서 잠은 재우면서 밥은 안 먹게
네 어? 근데 너무 불안해요
가슴 막 두근거리고
아 그러면 진정제를 좀 쓰고
심박동을 낮추는 약을 쓰면 되겠다
이런 식으로 막 가는 거예요
그럼 뭐가 안 좋아요?
그냥 급사하죠 이것도
딴 거 다 올라가서 다른 걸 다
다른 걸 하나하나 다 낮추면
근데 그게 사실 심박동을 올리는 건 현상이고
이 기전이 굉장히 다양하거든요
근데 이건 사실 하나의 현상
그러니까 스트레스 호르몬으로
이런 레벨이나 이런 아드레날린 같은 호르몬들이
올라갔다는 걸 뜻하는 건데
이 약은 이 심박동을 낮추는 약인 거예요
이 호르몬들은 그대로 있고
그러면은 이게 안 맞는 거예요 몸이
그래서 흔히 말하는 우리 몸에서
이런 그 항상성을 조절하는 시스템이
좀 꼬인다고 표현을 해요
특히 딱 저런 거
각성제를 쓰면서 수면제를 쓰면 어떻게 될까
이런 거 막 연구해 본 적이 있거든요
이게 수면도 아니고 각성은 이상한 상태가 돼요
근데 눈은 감고 있었는데
실제 우리가 수면에 의해서 기대하는 것들이
안 이루어지는 거죠
그래서
호르몬들의 어떤 그 상태가 이게 엉망이 돼서
살이 빠지면은 그래서 수명이 늘어야 되잖아요
건강해져야 되잖아요
살이 빠지는데 수명이 늘기는 개뿔
빨리 죽어요
너무 빨리 죽고 너무 막 급사하고
특히 이렇게 암페타민 같은 것도
이것도 혈관 쪽 그리고 심장 이쪽으로 해가지고
급사 리스크 확 올리거든요
기본적으로 저게 약간 중독 경향이 있어서
양이 점점 늘어나게 돼요
조금만 넣어도 중독되게 돼요
점점 점점 더 많이 먹게 돼요
저희 마약이잖아요
그렇죠 일종의 약간
그래서 옛날 거는 뭐 더 안 좋았으니까 지금보다
그래서 이때부터 칵테일 약
무지개 알약 다이어트
왜 무지개 알약이냐
빨조노초파남보
알약 세 개 다 그래요?
아니요 그냥 약이 여러 개
아 여러 개가 있어요?
근데 지금 우리나라에서 이런 데가 또 있어요
약을 이렇게 쓰는 데가 있고요
비슷해요
여기에 뭐 진정제 인효제 카페인
뭐 흔히 말하는 나비약 같은 성분
그거랑 다른 또 종류의 항우울제 중에
식욕 낮추는 막 이런 것들이랑
간질량 중에 또 식욕 낮추는 그런 약들이 있어요
그런 것들을 섞어서 한 일곱 개 정도 약 만들어가지고 주면은
사람이 밥을 먹을 수 있겠어요?
못 먹어요
못 먹으면은
빠지지
살이 빠지죠
사실 무지개 다이어트 알약 1920년대 나왔는데
100년 동안 이게 유지가 되고 있는 거네
이 성분만 다르게
네 우리나라에서 하고 있고
아마 다른 나라는 어쩐지 잘 모르겠어요
있을 것 같아 다른 나라도
근데 우리나라도 이게 아직까지 좀 남아있긴
그러니까 지금은 이제 많이 좀 줄어지긴 했어요
근데 그런 거 하면은 대부분 이게 진짜 안 좋게 돼요
그러니까 내장지방 오히려 늘어나고
오히려
급사항률도 올라가고
그러니까 장수를 못해요
이렇게 하면 수명이 깎여요 진짜
그리고 이게 더 음식 중독 같은 거 더 심해지고
궁금한 거
보약으로 하는 거 있잖아요
한의원에서
그런 거는 이런 거랑 또 다른 거예요?
그게 약간 이제 마황 그쪽인데
그것도 기본적으로는
효과가 엄청 좋다거든요
보약 다이어트처럼
식욕 억제요 식욕 억제
그것도 약간 그 우리 몸의 스트레스 레벨이 높아지게 해가지고
식욕이 억제되는 거거든요
어떻게 보면은 그 성분 자체는 비슷해요
근데 식욕 억제도
다양한 기전이 있어요
그러니까 GLP-1이나 GIP의 어떤 식욕 억제의 기전이 있고
우리 뇌에서 도파민이나 스트레스 레벨을 높여서
교감신경을 항진시켜가지고
스트레스 받아서 안 먹게 하는 게 있거든요
조금 그런 스트레스 레벨을 높여서 못 먹게 하는 거여서
그것도 부작용이 수면 부족 불면 이런 게 좀 생겨요
그러니까 다이어트의 목적이 건강을 위해선데
그거에 이제 좀 부합하지 않는 방법인 경우가 많아요
그래서 여러분 진짜 재밌는 건데
GLP-1 나오기 전까지
세상에 다이어트 약 진짜 많았죠
그리고 뭐 화장실에서
한약도 있고 진짜 많죠
근데 이렇게 해서 살 빼가지고
당연히 비만인 사람이 살 빠지면은
생존이 늘어나야 되는데
심근경색이나 뇌돌증이나
수명이 늘어났다라는 연구가
좀 대규모된 게 있는지 한번 찾아보세요
하나도 없어요
그런 연구는 우리들은 찾아보지 않아요
아 그럴 수 있겠다
선생님 우리들을 뭘로 아시는 거예요
우리들은 그런 거 안 봐요
연구 결과 영어로 돼 있잖아요
어떻게 보라는 거예요
아 그쵸
수명을 늘려주는 게 그게 너무 약간 딜레마였던 거
아니 왜 당연히 살 빠졌으면
살아야 되는데
왜 수명이 안 늘어나지
왜 심근경색 뇌돌증이 안 줄어들지
오히려 급사하는 사람만 자꾸 있고
그래서 퇴출된 약만 계속 있지
그런 약이 없었는데
GLP-1 제재가 사실 나온 지 여러 번 꽤 됐어요
저 레지던트 때 나왔으니까
이제 뭐 거의 한 15년 이렇게 가까이 돼요
이제 사실 되게 오래된 약이에요
근데 저 아직도 레지던트 그때
그 사람들이 엄청 좋아했던 게 기억나요
왜냐면 저 그때 잘 모르니까
당뇨병 약이 새로 나왔대요
당뇨병이 새로 나왔어
그때 이제 당뇨병 약을 써서
당뇨병 환자들의 수명이 늘어났다고 좋아하는 거예요
들으면서 레지던트 때 어렸을 때 하니까
저게 뭔 소리지
아니 당연히 수명이 늘어나야 되는 거 아니야
그랬는데 생각보다 당뇨병 약재도
뉴트럴하거나 부작용 합병증
그러니까 눈이 막 먼다거나 투석하거나
이런 거를 좀 줄여주긴 하는데
진짜 명백하게 심근경색을 낮춰주거나
명백하게 수명을 늘려주는 약이 별로 없었던 거예요
아주 약간 마일드한 정도
근데 그것도 또 뭐냐면
혈당이 좋아져서
그래 오래 살았네
딱 이 정도까지일 거예요
근데 혈당이 좋아지는 거 플러스로
뭔가 알파적인 더 생명 연장에
이런 게 있는 약은 없었는데
GLP-1이 처음에는 당뇨병 약으로 나왔었는데
이게 혈당 좋아지고 이런 걸 떠나서
뭔가 사람을 오래 살게 해줬다는 거예요
그래서 엄청 좋아했어요 의사들이
그럼 진짜 신의 약물이네
아직까지는 밝혀진 바에 의하면
지금까지는 대사질환 쪽에서 GLP-1 제재가
혁신적이었어요 저 레지던트 때
압도적
그래서 솔직히 말해서
다양한 경구 약재들도 있어요
경구 약재들도 있는데
약재도 잘 맞는 사람들은 그걸로 잘 빼고 할 수 있어요
근데 그건 굉장히 약도 잘 쓰고
본인도 굉장히 잘 하고 맞는 케이스인 건데
그 레벨이 여긴 옛날에 총 같은 느낌이었다면
발전 정도가 약간 미사일?
약간 그 다음 전쟁?
칼과 총 정도의 느낌의 차이가 좀 있어요
약을 쓰는 입장에서
확 그게 레벨이 달라졌구나
격이 확 벌어졌어요
근데 이거 별개로
또 약간 이런 궁금증도 있는데요
예를 들어 한약 다이어트라든지
다른 약간 몸에 무리를 주는 다이어트가 있어요
근데 이제 되게 고도비만이에요
그 자체로 이미 건강이 안 좋아요
그걸 되게 몸에 무리를 줘가지고 줄여들면은
비만에 의해서 다른 합병증 같은 게 다 줄어들 거 아니에요
뭐가 더 나은 거야 굳이 따지면
그러니까 그런 사람들이 이제는
GLP-1을 쓰면서 살을 빼는 게 제일 좋아요
압도적으로 제일 좋아요 GLP-1은
그건 제일 좋고 그냥 뭐 일반적인 몸에 무리가 되는
일반적인 것도 근데
일반적인 다이어트를 한다고 하면
전문가랑 해야 돼요
왜냐면 이게 기본적으로는
굉장히 강한 식욕 억제제라
몸에 약간 스트레스 약간 주는 게 있거든요
이거 하면서 먹는 거를 조금이라도 바꾸는 사람
걷는 거를 조금이라도 바꾸는 사람
이런 사람들은 되게 좋아요
근데 그냥 약만 했다 그러면은
진짜 대부분 오히려 이후에 요요가 오는데
요요가 오면서 항상 체성분 나빠져요
여러분 아셔야 될 거
나는 살을 항상 쪘다 빠졌다 빠졌다 해요 라고 하는데
그거 그대로 쪘다 빠졌다는 거 100% 아니에요
무조건 빠질 때는 근육이 좀 빠지고요
찔 때는 지방이 다 빠져요
왔다 갔다 하면 더 안 좋네
항상 체성분은 손해에요
약간 주식도 그렇잖아요
뭔가 왔다 갔다 왔다 갔다 왔다 하면은 손해 보잖아요
결국에 내가
수술을 줘야 되니까
약간 그런 식으로 항상 손해에요
이런 약 쓰다가 우리 조상님이 이런 약 썼어요
이건 약도 아니지 뭐
하여튼 GLP-1은 생각보다 발견된 거
그렇게 오래 안 됐어요
한 80년대였나
그때 이제 여기에 있는 조엘 헤버너 박사랑
앤스 유 헐스트라는 박사가
각각 이제 연구하다가 발견했거든요
근데 이 사람은 이제 그 악의에 대해서는
GLP-1이라는 걸 찾았던 사람이고
그것도 처음에 진짜 우연이었어요
이 사람도 진짜 엄청 대단한 사람인데
얼마나 돌아가셨거든요
노발생 못 받고 결국 돌아가셨는데
우리가 알고 있었던 글루카곤이라는 호르몬이 있어요
그러니까 GLP 이름 자체가 뭐냐
글루카곤 라이펩타이드 원이에요
이름 자체가 글루카곤이랑
비슷하게 생긴 단백질 넘버원
그걸로 부르고 있어요
이게 어떤 단독 이름이 붙은 게 아니라
그러니까 이 사람이 처음에 보고
아 이거 내가 단백질 찾았는데
이거 췌장에서 나오는
글루카곤이랑 닮았어 라고 한 거거든요
왜냐면 이 사람이 그 당뇨병 이런 거
혈당 조절에 관심 좀 있어가지고
인슐린이 혈당 낮추는 호르몬인 건 다 알죠
혈당을 낮추는 호르몬이 인슐린이고
췌장에서 또 나아가지고
혈당을 올리는 호르몬이 글루카곤이에요
그래서 보통은 식 후에는 인슐린이 나오고
식 전에는 글루카곤이 나오고 있죠
그렇게 혈당을 이렇게 조절하는 건데
이 사람이 아 인슐린과 글루카곤을 우리가 알면은
혈당은 우리 마음대로 조절할 수 있겠다
라고 막 보고 찾아보다가
보니까 글루카곤이랑 비슷하게 생겼는데
다른 단백질이 있네
그래서 glp-1이라고 이름을 지었던 거예요
아기 검사해보다가 이 사람 사람에서 하고
정말 대단한 발견한 거 아니에요
그쵸
근데 상을 안 줬네요
아직 못 받고 죽었어요
아마 받을 건데
죽었으면 못 받죠 이제
자기 와이프한테 말했대요
나 노벨상 받을지도 모르겠다
그때 80년대
그거 찾은 다음에 이게 뭐가 될 줄 알았던 거죠
그래서 뭐 이 사람 뭐 대박났죠
왜냐면 이거 다 약됐잖아요 지금
유고비나 이런 거 이 사람 다 했을 거니까
그럼 뭐가 이게 있어요
당연히 있겠죠
엄청나게 돈 많이 버셨겠죠
아니 그러니까 확실히 우쌤이
이런 거에 굉장히 딱 집중을 하시는 게 있어요
돈을 되게 많이 벌어야 됐겠는데
엄청나지 않을까요
세 개를 지금 뭐 이렇게
근데 이 사람은 동료였거든요
이 사람 약간 좀 지금 되게 서운해요 이 사람은
스페틀라나 모이소부
네 이분은 왜
왜냐면은 이 사람이 glp-1 관련해
첫 번째 그 논문을 썼어요
일 저자로
그러면 사실 이 사람도 엄청난 업적이고
이 사람이 사실
그때 진짜 활발하게 활동하다가
이제 아이 출산 육아 이런 거 때문에
필드에서 좀 떠나있다가 다시 좀 복귀하고 이렇게 했거든요
근데 그 과정 속에서 노벨상 후보로 올라가는 거라든지
그 얼마 전에 또 이 세대 사람 상 받았거든요
그 상도 못 받고
그리고 제약회사에 이런 약의 어떤 그 특허권 같은 거 할 때
개런티 하잖아요
그걸 못 받았어요 이 사람이
근데 그때 임신을 해가지고 잠깐 떠나 있었던 거예요
그건 뭐 정확히는 모르겠는데
그런 일련의 어떤 거치의 이동을 해서
개런티 금액 같은 거 못 받은 거예요
그래서 이 사람이 최근에 막 이런 걸로 좀 소송도 좀 걸고
좀 그러고 있는 거예요
좀 해탈한 표정이긴 하네요
왜냐면 이게 너무 크잖아요 사실
이게 너무 크고
또 하필 glp-1이 지금 전 세계에 엄청난 파급력을 비치고 있고
또 어떤 문장들이 나오냐면은 glp-1이 지금 이제 사람들이
어 이제 다 안다 해서 끝인 것 같지만
glp-1은 이제 오프닝이다라는 이야기를 많이 해요
이제
이제 오프닝이다
왜냐면 이 다음에 나오는 다양한 효과들
지금 새로 나오는 약제들은요
한 달짜리 막 이런 거 있거든요 릴리에서
이거는 아예 처음부터 지금 연구를
조현병이나 조울증이나 알코올 중독 이런 것도 같이 진행하고 있어요
아예 약간 정신과적인 약처럼 쓸 수도 있겠다
너무나 이제 확장성이 너무 넓은데
너무 억울하겠다
너무 억울하죠
그러니까 뭐 일단 뭐 돈도 돈인데 인정을 못 받잖아
공식적으로 좀
그래서 노벨상 수상이 되려나 안 되려나
이 분 돌아가셨으니까 되려나 모르겠어요
헤어스타일이 너무 넋살림
아 약간 좀 랩 잘하실 것 같은 느낌이긴 한데
하여튼 엄청난 대가들이다라는 거고
그래도 얼마 전에 그 사진 돌아가시기 전에
이렇게 찍었던 게 있더라고요
그래서 가져왔고
근데 glp-1을 찾았어요
찾았는데 이거를 써보니까
혈당이 기가 막히게 떨어지는 거예요 사람한테
이걸 또 어디서 착안했냐면
우리가 병원에서 포도당 주사 맞잖아요
그 포도당을 입으로 먹이는 거랑
혈관으로 주사를 하는 거랑
들어가는 포도당은 똑같죠
혈당이 오르는 건 다르죠?
맞아요
뭐가 더 많이 올 것 같아요?
먹는 거
땡
와 2분의 1인데
네
틀렸어
아니 왜냐하면 병원에서 주사로 하니까 나는
주사가 더 좋은 거 아니야?
주사로 맞는 게 혈당이 훨씬 많이 올라요
근데 왜 그런지를 봤더니
이게 그 glp-1 때문이었어요
입으로 먹으면 이게 유장관에서 glp-1 자극이 돼가지고
glp-1이 나오면 혈당이 잘 떨어져 인슐린이 확 나와가지고
그래서 이걸로 우리 당뇨병약 만들면 되겠다라는 생각을 했어요
그랬는데 이 glp-1을 분리했죠
분리해서 보니까 이게 반감기 약제의 농도가 절반이 되는 시간 있죠
이게 2분인 거예요
이러면 약을 어떻게 만들어요?
기껏 해가지고 주사했는데 2분 뒤야 그거 떨어져
이거는 안 되잖아요
그래서 포기 상태였는데
이게 또 사람이 진짜 세상에 답을 찾으면 또 답이 있다고
독도마뱀이라는 게 있어요
너무 귀엽게 생겼어요
얘 진짜 특이하거든요
뭐가 특이하냐
1년에 이게 진짜인지 모르겠는데 식사를 한 4번 안 돼요
계절마다 하네?
네
엄청 큰 놈을 먹은 다음에 천천히 소화 흡수 시키는 거예요
그래서 이런 생각을 했대요
시간이 긴 glp-1 우리 찾으면 대박이다 이런 생각을 계속하고 있었는데
얘는 뭔가 소화 흡수 시간이 너무 길잖아요
포켓몬스처럼 생겨가지고 말도 안 되게 조금 먹고
심지어 동작도 느려요
그게 독도마뱀인데 동작이 되게 느려가지고 위협이 하나도 안 된대요
그래서 얘는 좀 소화 효소가 좀 다른가? 봤는데
인간 glp-1이랑 좀 비슷하긴 한데
이거의 작용 시간이 4-5시간 되는 거예요
인간은 2분이었는데
그래가지고 독도마뱀의 glp-1을 이제 추출해가지고
좀 변형을 해가지고 약으로 써본 거예요
그게 처음 나온 glp-1 체제였어요
아 그럼 제꺼야?
독도마뱀 처음 시작은
지금은 이제 인간 거랑 거의 비슷하게 합성을 하는데
내꺼지롱 메롱 이렇게
네
애꺼한 거예요
어떻게 사는지 모르겠어요 진짜
어떻게 독도마뱀한테 glp-1 4-5시간 가는 거 어떻게 알아가지고
저걸 썼는지 진짜 모르겠는데
진짜 대단하다
근데 지금 이제 우리가 맞는 glp-1
우리가 이제 흔히 알고 있는 이제 위고빈 세마글로타이드
이거는 우리 몸에서 나오는 glp-1 호르몬이랑 거의 94%가 일치해요
거의 똑같이 생겼어요
근데 그 다른 6%가 뭐냐
애가 반감기가 원래 2분이었잖아요
그거를 늘리려고 분해하는 효소가 또 있어요
분해한 효소가 못 달라붙게
그 부위를 좀 아미노산 배를 수정시키고
또 이게 알보빈 같은 다른 단백질에 오래 붙어있게
그 부위를 좀 수정시키고
야 그걸 다 개졸한 거구나
아 그걸 개조한 거예요
그럼 위고빈 마음자로 살이 왜 빠지나
네 뭐 진짜 이게 생각보다 여러 가지 기전이 있어요
사람들이 보통 아는 거는 이거죠
배가 부르고 배가 덜 고프더라
워낙에 이거에 대한 간증이 많으니까
식욕이 줄어들어요 아는 것처럼
근데 사실 그것뿐만이 아니에요
훨씬 복잡해요
왜 이거를 처음에 속 시원하게 말 못했는지 알아요
몰라요
의사들도 몰랐기 때문에 그래요
모르는데 현상은 일어나
네 그래서 처음에 난리가 났어요
왜냐면 glp-1 저거는 당뇨병인 줄 알았어요
당뇨병 약이었어요
당뇨병 약이니까 혈당 너무 잘 떨어져 너무 좋아
근데 환자들이 살이 점점 빠져요
이게 엄청 옛날이야 이게 2000년대에요
2000년대에 환자가 살이 빠져
심지어 그게 당뇨병 환자야
이거는 열의 아홉은 굉장히 불안한 징후에요
보통은 암이야
아 이거 암 생기나 보다
아니면 근감소 이런 거 오나 보다
그러니까 안 좋은 거
네 무조건 안 좋은 거지
사람이 살이 좀 빠지면
50세 아저씨가 갑자기 약 쓰더니
당뇨병 환자야
10kg 빠졌어
후착해졌어
이 사람이 이제 갈 때가 됐나
왜냐면 갑자기 살이 빠진다는 거는
흔히 우리 말하는 레드 플래그 사인이라고 해요
가장 안 좋은 그런 것 중에 하나여서
나이 들었을 때 살이 빠진다는 거
그렇죠
그래서 너무 그래가지고
연구를 엄청 했어요 그때
엄청 검사했는데 안 나오는 거예요
왜 빠지는지 모르겠는데 안 나와
근데 이게 보니까 사람들이 덜 먹는다는 거예요
입맛이 없다는 공통된 증언이
그래서 보통은 이제
사람 몸이 안 좋아지면 입맛이 떨어져요
원래 염증이 증가하거나
그래서 염증에 대한 검사도 막 다 해봐요
염증이
없어
좋아졌어
근데 입맛이 없대
자꾸 이제 부정적인 거 아닐까 해서
부정적인 걸 찾아봐도 안 나와
네 안 나와
그래서 그냥 그때 인정하기로 한 거예요
그냥 덜 먹어서 살이 빠진 거다
그래서 처음에 그렇게 안 먹어서 살 빠진다는 게
그때 나온 거예요
그냥 환자들의 증언과 현상으로
그걸 이렇게 이야기하고
근데 암은 진짜 몇 년 동안 찾았는데 안 나왔어
그러니까 또 제약회사가 어떤데요
비만 시장 안 그래도 엄청 컸는데
야 이거 비만약 만들어야겠다
그래서 용량을 늘려갔어요
더 빠져 사람들이 더 못 먹어서
응
그래서 용량을 올려가지고
비만인데 당뇨병이 없는 사람한테 써가지고 해보니까
다 좋아졌어 오래 살아
뭐 문제없어 살 빠져
그냥 그게 출시된 거야 일단
그런 다음에 이 약제의 그 기전에 대한
자세한 연구가 같이 이루어지기 시작한 거야
기전은 모르고 뒤에 있는 현상은 별 문제가 없으니까 내자
별 문제가 없는 건 몇 년 동안 우리가 확인을 했고
그럼 이제 기전을 이제 알아보자
네
그래서 이제 기전에 대한 연구가 계속 이루어진 거예요
그래서 계속 나오고 있는 거고
지금도 나오고 있어요
그 기전에 대한 이야기가
아직도 지금 다 100% 밝혀진 게 아니에요
그쵸
왜냐면 이 glp-1이라는 게 호르몬이잖아요
네
호르몬은 수용체가 우리 몸의 온갖 장기에 다 있어요
그래서 이 장기에 가서는 뭘 하는지
면역세포에도 심지어 glp-1 수용체가 있어요
면역세포한테서도 하는 효과가 있어요
면역세포도 좀 순해져요
처음에 염증이 떨어지는 게
아 살 빠져서 떨어지나 좋아지나 보나 했는데
그게 아니라 면역세포도 염증 정도가 낮아질 거예요
뭔가 흔히 말하는 성과가 낮아지고
성과가 좀 떨어지는 그런 작용들이 있었던 거예요
그래서 나왔던 게 그때 뇌에 대한 검사해봤죠
또 알고 있는 식욕 조절되는 것들이 있어요
포만감 시그널이랑 흔히 말하는 배고픔 시그널
근데 그것들이 뇌에서 확실히 작용을 하고
아 여기에도 이게 큰 단백질이어서
못 갈 줄 알았는데 뇌에 막 다 막아져 있고
아 이게 좀 가는구나
이제 그런 걸 좀 알게 된 거고요
또 요새 알게 된 거는 쾌락적 식욕
제가 일단 이야기 드릴 텐데
이게 측좌액에서 우리가 그냥 담배 필 때
도박할 때
이럴 때 나오는 그 도파민이 있어요
이게 감소예요
동물실험 막 해보고 하니까
근데 사실 비만 환자분들이 진짜 힘든 게
약간 중독이 있는데
중독 환자가 제일 힘든 게 뭐냐면
이걸 중독이라고 인정하지 않는 사람들 사이에 있으면
진짜 힘든 거예요
왜냐면 이걸 그냥 의지 문제라고 이야기해버리니까
근데 그거에 좀 작용을 한다는 거
진짜 배고플 때만 먹고 싶고
쾌락을 느끼고 싶어서 먹고 싶은 거는 많이 줄어든다
그렇죠
그리고 근육이랑 지방세포에도 작용을 해요
지방세포도 흔히 말하면
그 인슐린이 좀 작용을 하는 그런 게 있거든요
근데 이런 인슐린에 대한 대사의 민감성이 좀 좋아져요
그래서 훨씬 지방세포도 좀 안정되고
근육세포들도 좀 안정되고
그렇게 대사가 전체적으로 원활해지는 게 있고
혈당 조절이 원활해져요
그러니까 일단 기본적으로 당뇨병 약이에요
당뇨병 약인데 진짜 좋은 거는 뭐냐
위고비나 마온자루나 저혈당을 진짜 적어요
이게 굉장히 강한 당뇨병 약이거든요
사람들이 이걸 잘 몰라
여러분 인슐린 알죠?
하루에 한 번씩 맞는 거
이 인슐린을 맞기 싫어하는 사람이 진짜 많아요
매일 주사를 맞아야 되고
저혈당도 생기고 무섭고 이러니까
근데 당뇨병 약제의 강도 측면에서
이 glp-1이 오히려 하루에 한 번 맞는 인슐린 매일 맞는 거
이것보다 더 강해요
혈당 강화 효과가
그리고 비만 약제로 처음에 나왔던 거는
심지어 그렇게 강한 당뇨병 약제 용량의 2배였어요
그럼에도 불구하고 저혈당이 없는 거는
혈당이 올라갈 때 인슐린 분비를 지켜요
근데 인슐린은 혈당이 있든 없든 무조건 들어와서
혈당을 낮춰버리니까 저혈당이 많은 거고
경고 약제 중에서도 인슐린을 보통 올리는 애들은
혈당 있는지 없는지 모르겠고
난 무조건 인슐린 분비하게 해
이런 식으로 조절 기능이 없어서 저혈당이 그렇게 많이 오는데
glp-1은 딱 혈당이 올라갈 때 분비로 확 초점시키고
혈당이 떨어지면 일진 분비를 안 시켜요
엄청 좋은 거잖아요
그래서 좋은 거죠
그래서 굉장히 좋은 거다라는 건데
좋은 거밖에 없네
근데 그만큼 이 약을 먹는다는 거는
굉장히 강한 당뇨병 약제예요
강한 신호 호르몬의 자극을 뇌한테 주는 건데
이거를 적절하게 해주지 않으면
어떤 호르몬과 대사의 왜곡이 생긴다는 거
그만큼 이거 되게 강한 약제라는 걸 아셔야 돼요
그리고 다 알 거예요 위장관동 느려지는 거
왜 위장관동 느려지냐
식후 호르몬이기 때문에 그래요
그래서 위장관동 느려지는 거는 장점은 사실 보여요
신창규 님이 라면을 먹었어요
그러면 위장관동이 엄청 빠르면 혈당이 이렇게 올라가요
근데 물리적으로 glp-1을 맞으면 천천히 내려가니까
똑같은 걸 먹어도
혈당이 올라가니까
똑같은 걸 먹어도 혈당이 올라가니까
천천히 올라가요
근데 그 말은 뭐냐
혈당이 빠르게 올라가면 훨씬 더 많은 인슐린이 필요하고요
근육으로 가는 것보다 지방으로 가는 게 무조건 많아요
이 올라가는 거는 한 번에 처리를 못 하니까
일단 지방으로 밀어넣는 게 되거든요
지방으로 밀어넣게 되는데 느려지니까
그냥 근육으로 갈 포션이 많아져요
쌤이 그 단백질 먼저 먹으라고 하는 거랑 비슷한 거예요?
비슷한 거예요
그러니까 glp-1을 분비하게 하는 식단이
사실 제일 유명한 게 단백질이랑 수용성 식이섬유예요
이 두 개가 들어가면 glp-1이 나와요
그럼 이것도 좋은 거고
좋은 거죠
이거는 사실 약간 독도마뱀이 저렇게 해가지고
군기 하나 먹는 건가요?
이게 극단적으로 그래서?
걔는 진짜 극단적으로 천천히 흘러보내니까
이거 한 번 먹은 거를 거의 한 3-4개월 먹겠죠
이야 독도마뱀 진짜 걔는 좋겠다
난 생각은 내가 생각하고 몸은 독도마뱀이 되고 싶다
야 1년에 한 4번 먹고 싶다
걔 되려나?
위장관에 계속 있으면서
정말 밸런스 잡힌 그 영양소가
소장으로 천천히 내려가게
설계를 하면은 모르겠어요
그게 언젠가 될지 안 될지
근데 생각보다 덩치가 작을수록 원래는
턴오버가 빨라가지고
적절한 에너지 공급이 있어야 되거든요
아 쉽지는 않을 것 같다
GIP는 뭐예요?
이게 마온자로에 들어있는
사실 마온자로는 본체가 이거예요
위고비는 본체가 이거고요
마온자로는 본체가 이거 GIP라는
큰일들 위고비 업그레이드 버전이 마온자로라고 하는데
그냥 다른 종류예요?
좀 달라요
GIP란 호르몬은 이게 사실 glp-1보다 더 먼저 발견됐는데
앞으로 나오고 처음 가거든요
GIP는 이거는 식후에 나와서 혈당을 좀 낮춰주는 건데
glucose-dependent insulinotrophic protein이라고 해가지고
혈당을 낮춰주는 호르몬인데
얘는 포만감에 있어서는
어떤 연구 해보니까 포만감을 올려주기도 하고
어떤 연구 해보니까 배를 고프게도 하는 거예요
그리고 혈당 강화 효과도 glp-1보다 막 그렇게 안 쎄
아 뭐야 얘는 되게 애매하네
연구들도 맨날 왔다 갔다 하고
주로 지방 먹으면 나오는 얘는
그래서 뭔가 애매해가지고
연구가 이제 좀 안 되고 있다가
일라이를리에서 glp-1과 같이 해보니까
굉장히 좋은 효과가 있더라
식욕 억제나 위장 간의 어떤 이런 움직임 같은 것들
이번에 같이 병합제로 해서 glp-1가 나온 거다라고 하고
여기 보면 푸딩테크는 늘리는 연구도 있고 줄이는 연구도 있고 하는데
glp-1과 같이 오면 내려요
그럼 마온자는 저 두 개를 섞은 거예요?
지금 섞은 거예요
근데 이거는 조금이고 이게 좀 메인
그래서 glp-1은 진짜 메인이 뭐냐
약간 이런 인슐린 감수성을 계속
선호해주는 거고
지방대사 측면에서 되게 재밌는 측면이 있어서
그 위고비와 마온자의 그 차이가 벌어져요
정상 체중 환자에서도 glp-1을 주면은 덜 먹어요
심지어 아 이게 씹을 때부터 포만감 호르몬이 올라오는구나
이게 그냥 입에 넣고 씹으면 안 삼켰잖아요
그때부터 사람들이 배부르다고 하고
확실히 배고프면 덜 느껴요
그러니까 이거는 뭐 체중에 상관없이 거의 뭐든
근데 인구의 한 10% 정도 효과가 떨어지는 거다
사실 이게 체중이 감소하는 메인 커즈이긴 해요
식욕이 떨어지고
그러니까 배부르다라는 게 메인 커즈라는 건데
이 중독에 대한 이야기가 최근에 진짜 많이 나오는 거예요
솔직히 말해봐요
배고파서 먹어서 살찐 사람이 있을까요?
이건 배부르면 그만 먹는데
네 위장이 너무 커서
아 위장이 너무 커서
채우고 싶어 배고파
그건 좀 이야기를 좀 나눠봐야 되긴 하는데
그러니까 말씀 주신 게 어느 정도 일리는 있는 게
사실 배부름이다라는 거는 두 가지가 작용을 하는 겁니다
첫 번째는 위장 간의 팽창이긴 해요
근데 이거는 물을 많이 마셔도 배부르다고 느껴요
근데 그거는
금방 배고파지죠
그리고 국수 같은 건 3인분 먹어
배부르죠
근데 그거 한 2시간이나 하면 다시 배고파지거든요
그러니까 위 팽창감은 굉장히 일시적인 포만감이에요
그러면 칼로리인가 싶기도 하잖아요
근데 여러분 콜라를 1리터 마셔봐요
배 별로 안 불러요
하나도 안 불러요
칼로리가 엄청 되는데
그래서 배부름이라는 거는
결국 생리적인 배부름이라는 건 호르몬이에요
GLP-1, GIP, CCK, PYY 이런 포만감의 호르몬이 있거든요
이것에 의해서 조절되는 식욕이라는 것은
그냥 배가 부르기 때문에 그만 먹게 돼요
그래서 살이 안 쪄요
이걸 생리적 허기라고 표현하거든요
생리적 허기는요
배가 고프면 먹고 배가 부르면 그만 먹어요
그렇기 때문에 살이 안 쪄요 생각보다
근데 왜 사람들이 살이 찌냐는 이야기가 나오고
이거 보니까 식욕이라는 거는
생리적 식욕뿐만이 아니라 항상성 식욕이라도 합니다
쾌락적 식욕이라는 게 있어요
Heathering Appetite라고 표현을 하는데
약간 술 담배처럼 재미로 음식을 먹는 그런 거예요
뭔지 알아요
스트레스 받은 사람이 계속 먹는 걸로
맞아요 스트레스 받을 때도 먹고요
좋은 일 있어도 먹어요 사실
너무 신나 야구 볼 때
맥주 마시고 막
맥주 마시고 하잖아요
근데 이게 약간 인간의 본능이긴 합니다
도파민 나오면 더 터뜨리고 싶어가지고
근데 이런 거는 대부분 다 식욕이 아니라 어떤 자극이에요
도파민, 엔도르핀, 세로토닌
약간 이런 뇌의 자극 때문에 먹는 건데
그러면 이거는 그냥 계속 들어가는 거예요
가끔 말씀하시는 분들 중에
아 저는 배가 불러도 계속 먹어요 라는 사람이 있어요
그거는 배가 고파서 먹기 시작한 게 아니었기 때문에 그래요
그러니까 생각해보셔야 돼요
배가 불러도 술 담배는 하잖아요
술 담배와 같은 레벨에 있는 특정 음식들을 섭취하는 거예요
그래서 아 이게 중독이 문제다라는 걸
이제 우리가 꽤 많이 알게 됐어요
그래서 이 쾌락적 식욕에 대한 작용을 약으로 좀 줄여줄 수 있나
이 연구가 최근에 좀 결과가 나왔어요
왜냐면 당뇨병 환자분들은 엄청나게 많아요
그래서 이 GLP-1 세마글루타이드 위곱이죠
릴라글루타이드는 이전에 싹 센다
그 성분의 약을 쓰는 사람들이 있으니까
그냥 보면서 이상하게
이 사람들이 음식 말고도 대마초, 마약, 술, 담배
이런 것들에 대한 소비가 어떻게 되는지 본 거예요
다른 거 안 하고
그래서 60만 명 봤어요 60만 명
3년이나
반대쪽은 혈당 관리는 이제 다른 약으로
SZ-2는 굉장히 좋은 약입니다
소변으로 콜라 한 캔 정도의 당을 배설하게 하는 약인데
이것도 수명 늘려요
두 개 본 거예요
새로운 물질 사용 장애가 생기는가
두 번째 이미 중독 있는 사람도 있잖아요
당뇨병 환자는 좋은 게 다 있어요
다 있습니다
이미 병력이 있으면 이 사람들이
죽거나 과다 복용하거나 병원에 입원하거나
이런 게 줄어들 수 있는가
좋아졌겠죠?
얼마나 좋아졌냐 문제죠
근데 생각보다 높았어요
보시면 전체 한 14%인데
쟤보다 훨씬 유의미하네요
새롭게 생기는 중독이
마약 중독은 거의 25% 정도
코카인도 한 20%
니코틴 20%
알코올 중독도 거의 한 18% 정도
대마초도 14% 정도 감소
그러니까 이걸 그냥 쓰고 혈당을 떨어뜨렸는데
중독이 왜 줄어들지?
이 사람들은 살 빼려고 한 것도 아닌데
혈당 조절하려고 쓴 거예요 이 사람들은
그래서 다른 걸 다 보정해도
새로운 중독 자체가 덜 생기는 거예요
그러면 이미 물질 사용 장애를 앓고 있는 사람들
마약 중독 사람 얼마나 많이 죽어요
그렇죠
못 끊고
봤는데 사망률이 반으로 줄었어요
이건 위고비 데이터거든요
응급실 방문도 31% 감소하고
입원도 26% 감소하고
아 이게 중독에 대해서
굉장히 좋은 효과를 보이는구나
그래서 실제 동물들도 해보니까 말한 대로
이 왜곡된 보상이 줄어드는 거예요
그래서 아예 이번에 새로 나오는
이런 GLP-1의
다른 신약들은
시작부터 정신과 질환들을 타겟으로 해가지고
연구가 지금 진행되고 있는 게 많아요
그리고 아까 말했던
그 위고비와 마온자로 다른 약이다
이게 진짜 아예 다른 약이에요
뭐 두 개 약간 스위칭했을 수도 있기도 한데
사람들이 마온자로는 GLP-1과 GIP
이게 듀얼 작용을 한다라고 알고 계신데
맞는 말입니다 맞는 말인데
그럼 위고비랑 똑같이 생긴 데다가
마온자로는 GIP를 붙여놓은 건가요?
그렇게 상상이 되잖아요
근데 그러면요 여러분
덩치가 너무 커져요
그래서 릴리가 고민을 한 거예요
이러면 이거 너무 커져가지고
이거 약으로 쓸 수가 없고
그렇게 단백질성이 크잖아요
주사했을 때 국소부작용이 너무 심해요
통증도 있고 이게 막 항체 생길 가능성도 높고
그래서 알러지 반응도 너무 심하게 있고
실제 이 마온자로가 위고비보다 커요
펩타이드 크기 자체가
그래서 주사했을 때 국소부작용이 좀 더 많아요
6% 정도니까 1%도 안 되니까
정말
10배 이상 더 많거든요
그래서 여기서 고민을 한 거
GLP-1 수용체의 모양을 알아요 릴리가
그 GLP-1 수용체의 모양을 알고
진해가 보기에 이 정도만 좀 누르면
GLP-1이 작용을 할 것 같아
라는 아이디어를 가지고
GIP의 백본을 일단 만들어요
GLP-1이랑 GIP에서 겹치는 부분이 있을 거 아니에요
이 겹치는 부분은 놔두고
GLP-1 중에서 우리가 생각하기에
최소의 부분만 이렇게 좀 해보자
그렇게 해서 마온자로가 만들어진 거예요
그래서 이 위고비랑 마온자로랑
어떤 형태적인 유사성을 보이는 곳은
거의 한 30% 정도밖에 안 돼요
근데 사람들은 100%에다가 뭘 붙였다고 생각하는데
그게 아니다
이거는 한 30% 정도만 갖고 있다
근데 거기서 어떤 약이 더 좋냐라는 게
약간 좀 어려워지는 이유가
그래서 이 마온자로는
이런 것들을 좀 고려하다 보니까
반감기 약제 농도가 절반이 되는 게 사실 5일이에요
위고비는 일주일 7일이에요
더 혈중 농도는 위고비가 조금 더 오래 지속이 돼요
그리고
위고비는 우리가 가지고 있는 GLP-1 호르몬과
유사성이 94%
거의 그냥 우리 거랑 똑같이 생겼어요
근데 마온자로는 조금 다르게 생긴 거죠
사실 어떻게 보면
그렇게 하다 보니까
이 GLP-1을 fully 이렇게 작용시켰을 때 나오는 효과와
이 GLP-1 수용체에 한 30-40% 정도만
일치시켜서 하는 효과가 같을 것이냐
여기에 대해서 사실 아무도 모르는 거죠
근데 그렇기 때문에 두 약제의 특성이 좀 달라요
그것도 이제 이야기 드릴 텐데
실제로 해서 마온자로는요
GIP에 대해서는 거의 효과를 다 보이는데
GLP-1에 대해서는 약간 효과가 떨어져요
활성화시키는 게
근데 위고비는 이 GLP-1에 대해서 효과가 거의
fully 있는 약제라는 거죠
그래서 용량을 스위칭할 때도
우리가 좀 고려해야 되는 것들이 많고
물론 용량 스위칭이 가능하긴 한데
전문가 의견을 좀 들어보셔야 되는 이유가
두 약제가 또는 다른 약제이기 때문에 그렇고
여러분 그 마온자로가 구역감이 덜하다라는 이야기를 해요
위고비보다
어떤 사람은 위고비가 좀 덜하다는 얘기죠
그렇죠 사람마다 좀 다르긴 한데
퍼센트로 봤을 때
구토를 하는 사람은 위고비가 좀 더 많아요
아 그래요
6%, 4% 연구가 좀 다르긴 한데
한 2% 정도 더 위고비보다 마온자로 구토가 낮거든요
처음에는 당연히 우리들이 위고비가 조금 더
위장관 운동을 정지시키는 거 있죠
그게 더 심할 거라고 생각했어요
당연히 위장관이 안 움직이니까 토하는 것일 것이고
그러면 위고비가 조금 더 위장관 운동을
더 많이 멈추게 하나고는요?
근데 왜 토하게 할까요?
근데 토하는 건 더 적잖아요
그걸 보니까 GIP가 뇌에 가서
약간 이런 구역감을 줄여주는 거예요
뇌의 작용이 있고
그래서 또 여러분들이 아셔야 될 거
피임약을 드실 때 마온자로를 투약하게 된다면
위장관이 운동이 좀 많이 느려지기 때문에
그 약물의 흡수가 조금 달라질 수가 있어요
흔히 말하는 AUC라고 약물 커브가
그래서 마온자로를 투약하게 된다면
위장관이 운동이 좀 많이 느려지기 때문에
그 약물의 흡수가 조금 달라질 수가 있어요
그래서 마온자로를 처음 투약한다면
한 달 정도는 약간 다른 물리적인 피임
콘돔 쓰신다든지
이런 것들을 한 달 정도는 하라고 이야기하는 이유가
흡수를 늦게 하니까
이게 지금 이 성분을 흡수를 못하는 거예요?
피임 성분을
이게 그 약물 상호작용은 아니라
흡수의 속도가 좀 느려지면서
이 커브가 좀 달라져서 그런 게 좀 있다
근데 GIP의 장점이 뭐냐
그러니까 위고비는 약간 중독 쪽에 대한 연구가 되게 많습니다
근데 마온자로는 지방대사 활성화에 대한 연구가 되게 많아요
이게 GIP의 특성인데
그러니까 마온자로를 맞는 사람들이
있잖아요
식후에는 포도당을 되게 잘 써요
그런데 공복이 길어지게 되면 지방을 좀 더 써요
이게 무슨 말이냐
지금 방장님이 살아있어요
그러면 지금 뭔가 에너지를 쓸 거 아니에요
우리가 쓰는 에너지는 포도당이랑 지방이에요
그런데 이 포도당의 지방이 비율이 있어요
비율이 마온자로를 맞고 공복이 길어지죠
그러면 지방의 비율이 올라가요
그냥 내가 살아가면서 사용하는 에너지의 비율이
지방이 좀 더 올라가는 거예요
그래서 그 간헐적 탄식을 하는 이유가 그거예요?
지방을 많이 쓰게 하는 거예요
네 마온자로를 하면서 간헐적 탄식 같은 걸 할 수 있죠
근데 그거 하실 때 꼭 걸어줘야 돼요
그러니까 마온자로를 한다
내가 살이 되게 많이 빠진다
그러면 혈중으로 지방산이 엄청나게 많이 나와요
그런데 이 혈중에 나오는 지방산을 여러분들이 걸어준다
그러면 그거를 태우게 돼요
근육이 연소를 시키거든요
그런데 안 그러면 지방산은 간으로 들어가고 그렇게 돼요
그러면 담석증의 확률이 올라가요
그게 독이 돼요?
그러면 여러분 수술할 수도 있고
담관염 생기면 폐혈증으로도 돼요
담석이 생겨서 좋은 것도 있나요?
하나도 없죠
하나도 없어요? 그럼 독이네요?
그렇죠
지방산을 빨리 해소를 안 하면
다른 데 가서 독이 된다는 거죠?
그렇죠 그래서 아셔야 될 게
체중이 빨리 빠지는 게 담석증의 확률을 올려요
얼마나 올리냐
연구에 따라서 1.6배, 2배, 3배까지 이렇게 올리는데
담석증은 담낭에 돌 생기는 거거든요
이게 또르르 굴러떨어져 가지고
담관을 막으면 담관염이 생기는 거고
꼬르르 덧떼러져 가지고
쾌장에 소화효소가 나오는 데를 막으면
쾌장염이 생기는 거예요
진짜 무서워요
운동은 필수네요?
최소 걷는 거 정도는
체중이 많이 줄어들면 들수록 운동은 해야 되나요?
많이 줄어들면
독이 퍼지니까?
담석증의 확률이 올라가니까
걷는 것도 진짜 잘 해주셔야 되고
그리고 감량 속도를 좀 조정해야 돼요
그리고 병원에서 상태를 보고
UDCA같이 부작용을 줄여줄 수 있는 약을
저희가 처방해 드리기도 해요
그렇게 전문가의 관리감도 있어야 돼요
생기면 너무 치명적이니까
그렇군요
그래서 이 GIP의 장점 중에 하나가 이거예요
공복에 지방을 좀 많이 쓰게 하고요
또 되게 재밌는 게
Fertile Cycle이라도 있거든요
이게 뭐냐면
지방에서 정말 쓸데없이 에너지를 쓰는 거예요
지방세포 내에서
옛날에는 우리가 열을 만들고 하는 것들이
그냥 근육에 있는
약간 이런 미토콘 이런 데서만 되는 줄 알았는데
마온자로를 쓰면서 보니까
이상하게 지방이 좀 잘 빠지고
뭐 이런 게 있어서
지방세포 내에서 약간 이렇게 에너지가 낭비가
낭비되면서 지방에 있는 저장된 지방산이 소모되는
이런 사이클들이 좀 돌아가요
그래서 지방이 조금 더 잘 빠질 수 있다
지방 대사를 좀 시킬 수 있다라는 이제 그런 게 있고
그래서 이제 마온자로를 한다 그러면
전 진짜 총에너지 섭취량을 낮추는 것도 좋지만
이 공복 시간을 확보하는 게 정말 좋다고 이야기를 해요
왜냐면 공복이 길어지게 되면은 에너지 연소를 하는 그 주소스가
주로 호흡으로 우리가 이제 이거 연구 많이 하는 REI라고
이게 우리가 포도당을 태운 거랑 지방을 태운 거랑
호흡의 어떤 그 분률이 달라요
하여튼 그 뭔가 이 간식을 섭취하지 않는 것
특히 마온자로 한다면은
그리고 저녁 식사를 좀 빨리 하는 것도 좋아요
공복의 시간이 길어질 수 있으니까
그래서 총에너지의 어떤 이런 다운과 함께
그 대사 유연성의 증가를 함께 고려하는 것들이 좀 필요하다
이런 게 악을 쓰는 좀 이런 아이디어 중에 하나에요
근데 마온자로를 안 하더라도
일반 생활에서 간헐적 단식하면 그 현상이 똑같다
일어나는 거 아니에요?
지방연소의 정도를 올리는 게
마온자로를 쓰는 거에 비하면은 좀 쉽지 않죠
훨씬 더 약한 버전으로 된
그렇죠 훨씬 더 오랜 시간 좀 더 많은 노력을 해야
그 정도의 지방연소율을 좀 올릴 수 있는 게 있고요
그리고 약간 인슐린 저항성 자체도 개선이 많이 되기 때문에
지방을 에너지로 쓰는 게 좀 수월해지긴 해요
근데 이 인슐린 저항성이 매우 심한 상태에서는
그냥 지방을 에너지로 못 쓰니까 배만 고파요
그래서 이제 이런 것들이 있다라는 거고
그리고 울렁거리는 거
이거에 대한 것도 사실
엄청 말이 많았죠 말이 많았는데
이것도 과거에 싹센다에서부터 울렁거림 이거 괜찮냐
옛날에 근데 저희가 농담처럼
울렁거렸던 사람들이 살이 많이 빠진다
이런 이야기 했었어요
울렁거리면 못 먹을 거 아니에요
아 울렁거린 사람은 더 못 먹어서 살이 빠지는가
그럼 반대로 이 생각을 할 수 있어요
안 울렁거리는 사람은 효과가 없나
근데 살이 똑같이 빠지는 거예요
근데 좀 울렁거렸던 사람들이 더 빠지는 경향이 보이긴 했어요
식욕이 없겠죠 울렁거리니까?
일단은 울렁거리다가 나중에 좋아지는
이제 괜찮아져요
최근에 나오는 연구들은
율고비나 마온자로 특히 이것도 율고비 쪽 데이터이긴 한데
울렁거림이 있는 유전적 특성이 있죠
이거랑 약재의 효과가 조금 더 좋은
이거랑 좀 결합되어 있을 확률이 높은 거예요
그래서 울렁거렸던 사람은
이 약재의 효과가 높을 확률이 좀 더 높더라
이게 아주 절대적인 지표는 아니지만
좀 그런 게 있었고
실제 율고비나 마온자로나
우리가 예전부터 계속 이유는 몰랐지만
현상적으로 3분의 1 정도는 되게 효과가 좋아
3분의 1은?
네 3분의 1 정도는 낮은 농도에서도 효과가 되게 좋고
살도 너무 잘 빠지고 대사적으로 너무 좋아지는 사람이 있고
한 3분의 1은 별로 안 빠지고
한 10%는 효과가 없고
그러니까 이것도 그 유전적인 다양성 때문에 10%는 효과가 없고
울렁거리는 사람은 효과가 좋을 유전자랑 같이 좀 이렇게
붙어 있는 경우가 많아서
아 울렁거리는 사람들이
너무 울렁거리는 거 아니야?
너무 탱구하고 울렁쇼미인데?
그래서 의사들이 약간 이렇게 설명을
이게 먹을 수 있는 정도예요?
못 먹는 정도예요?
잘 모르겠어요
다행히 보긴 해요
못 먹는 정도면 안 되니까
그래서 아까처럼 쉐이크 형태로라도 단백질 섭취할 수 있고
밥 그래도 먹을 수 있고 할 수 있냐 해서
먹을 수는 있다 라고 하면은
이제 그때 달래주기 위해서 이런 말 합니다
아 울렁거리는 것은
울렁거리는구나 또
약제 효과가 좋을 수도 있다는 시그널이기 때문에
우리 조금만 버텨보자라는 이야기를 드리고
근데 대부분 울렁거리는 거는 시간 지나면 좋아지긴 해요
얼마까지 가냐
조금 긴 거는 연구들 따르면 두 달 반까지 가기도 합니다
그 정도면 사실 안 맞는 거 아니야 라고 해서
그만둘 수도 있는 기간인데
그쵸
왜냐면 이게
너무 울렁거리는데?
그 증량을 하잖아요 계속
용량을 또 의사들이 견딜만 하면 증량을 한단 말이에요
익숙해지만 하면 또 울렁거리고
울렁거리고
여러분들 아셔야 될 게 위곱이를 맞잖아요
위곱이 할 때
아니 분명히 이거 익숙해진다 그랬는데
왜 계속 울렁거리나요 라고 물어보시는데
이게 처음 맞는 용량 그게 반감기가 일주일이라고 했잖아요
여러분들이 같은 용량을 네 번 맞아서
네 번 맞아서 같은 용량을 네 번 맞아서
사실은 증량하고 있는 거예요
몸에서 쌓여요 그게 계속
아 그렇구나
네 쌓여요
그러니까 같은 용량을
한 다섯 번 정도부터 맞으면 별로 안 울렁거리는 이유가
다섯 번째부터는 용량이 거의 비슷해지는 거예요
그래서 처음에 0.25를 맞았다
0.25가 절반될 때 그다음 용량이 들어오는 거고
이게 또 절반될 때 그다음 용량이 들어오는 거고
0.25 네 번 맞으면 체내 농도가 0.5 정도가 돼요
그래서 선생님이 그 마원자료를 안 맞는 사람이
계속 먹어버리고
버리면 이게 쌓여가지고 점점 위험해지는 것도 있겠네요
그쵸 그러니까 진짜 큰일 나는 거예요
진짜 봐봐요 10m 맞았어
아 나 죽을 거 같았지만 나 죽진 않았어
그럼 나 10m 또 할 수 있겠지
아니요 이제는 10점 매시 되는 거예요
그다음 걸 맞으면
그래서 진짜 큰일 나는 경우들이 생겨요
그래서 실제 콩팥이 망가져가지고 못 먹어서
투삭하거나 눈 실명하거나
심각하다
이런 게 생기기도 합니다
그래서 울렁거리는 거 괜찮은 건가 라고 했을 때
핵심 명제는 그겁니다
내가 나한테 필요한 정도의 탄수화물 단백질 지방을 먹을 수 있는가 없는가
못 먹는다 그러면 안 괜찮은 거예요
그거는 병원 가세요
의무실 가시거나 처방받는 데 가서
일단은 간격을 늘리든지 용량을 낮추든지 해야 되는 거다
내가 필요한 탄수화물 지방 단백질의 기준은 어떻게 알 수 있어요?
그거를 보통 병원 설정을 해줘야 돼요
제가 좀 간단하게 알려드리면
여러분들의 어떤 체중 곱하기
한 1.2에서 1.5까지는 단백질을 먹어야 돼요
그리고 식이섬유 하루에 한 25-30g
그중에 수용성 식이섬유가 한 5-10g은 돼야 됩니다
근데 자기 체중이 1.2라고 하면 내 체중이 80kg이면
거의 90g 먹어야죠 단백질은 최소
한 끼 30g 먹는 거예요
아 그니까 1.2라는 게 kg이 아니고
g으로
g per kg
그래서 뭐 코끼리와 뭐 해야 될지
그건 안 되죠
순단백질 기준으로 그렇게 되는 거고요
그리고 지방도 자기 총연량의 30% 정도는 먹어야 되고
특히 지방을 안 먹으면 담석질 확률이 올라가요
담낭이 담즙을 안 짜니까
근데 마훈자로 위곱이 맞으면 기름진 음식에 대한 선호도가 떨어져요
울렁거리니까 또 울렁거리기도 하고
뇌에서 실제 떨어져요 그게
그래서 기름진 거 안 먹는데
그러니까 이런 걸 의식적으로 먹어야 된다라는 걸 해서
이 정도 내가 필요한 거 먹을 수 있다
최소 아침
아침 이야기 진짜 많이 하는데
아침에 단백질 30g
탄수화물 없는 단백질 쉐이크에다가
두유나 우유 넣음 30g입니다
거기에다가 사과 반쪽
호두 한두 알
혹은 땅콩부터 조금
이 정도는 내가 아침으로 먹을 수 있는지
나 이거 도저히 못 먹겠다
그러면 약재를 좀 조절하는 게 좋을 수도 있다
조금 궁금한 게 있는데요
단백질을 쉐이크 같은 형태로 먹으면
가루 형태로 먹으면
자연에서 먹는 단백질보다 안 좋다는 얘기를 들었거든요
그렇지 않아요
원물로 먹을 수 있으면 좋죠
원물로 먹을 수 있으면 좋은데
단백질은 지방, 탄수화물이랑 좀 달라요
하이라키가
탄수화물이랑 지방은 CHO예요
구성 성분이
그러니까 두 개는 에너지예요 에너지
그런데
단백질은 CHON이라고 해가지고 질소가 들어있는 건데
이거는 그냥 우리 몸을 구성하는 벽돌이에요
그래서 우리 몸은요
생각보다 포도당도 만들 수 있고요
지방도 만들 수 있어요
내가 필요하면은
근데 단백질을 못 만들어요
단백질 외부에서 꼭 갖고 와야 돼
필수 아미노산이라고 하는 건데
우리가 식물이 아니니까
침착민 님 그냥 가만히 있는 거 같지만
몸의 근육은 하루에 1%씩 부서지고 다시 만들어져요
보수공사 해야지
보수공사 계속 해야 돼요
포도 블록도 새로 깔아야 되는데 사실은
찌니까
그리고 뭐야
지금 막 면역세포들
감기 한 번 걸리면 면역세포들 엄청나게 나왔다가
여러분 고름 하나 생기면 여드름 생기면
그 안에 지금 면역세포 시체가 얼마나 많은데
그 시체 다 단백질로 만들어지는 거고
그리고 머리도 자라고
다 단백질이에요
단백질이 다 너무 많아요 우리는
그러면 채식을 하면
채소에도 단백질이 있긴 하겠지만
많이 부족해진 경우에는
이 필수 벽돌이 안 들어오니까
문제가 생기겠네요
그래서 채식을 하시는 분들은
콩 같은 걸 많이 먹어야 되나?
아미노산의 밸런스를 되게 따져서
드셔야 돼요
당연히 이제 계란이나 고기류에는
흔히 말하는 필수 아미노산이
다 들어있는 경우들이 많거든요
근데 식물성 단백질
특히 뭐 밀이라든지 쌀이라든지
이런 데는 좀 부족하게 있는 경우가 많아요
단백질도 여러 종류예요
그쵸
그 단백질에서 질이라는 걸 따져요 우리가
그런데 우리가 라면
라면 뒤에 보잖아
단백질 10g 들었어
좀 있어x2
근데 10g이 되게 많네
그럼 나 라면 2개 먹으면 되겠네
라고 생각할 수 있어 20g 되니까
근데 그게 아닌 이유가
필수 아미노산의 어떤 조합의 완성도가
그러니까 필수 아미노산의 조합의 완성도가
이 밀단백질이 낮아요
계란 2개 넣어 드시면
그럼 총 단백질 양도 20g이 넘게 되고
단백질 전체의 아미노산의 구성도 좋아지게 되는
그럼 라면에다 계란 풀어 먹으면 되게 확 좋아지네요?
확 좋아져요
그럼 제가 또 들은 얘기가
단백질 또 너무 섭취하면
이게 또 독이 된다고 그러던데
그건 정말 너무 섭취하면
헬스 많이 할 때
이거 너무 많이 섭취하는 경우가 있다
그래서 너무 섭취하면인데
그게 왜 그런 말이 나오냐라고 한다면
CHON이라고 했잖아요
이 N 질소
이게 암모니아
이게 요소가 돼가지고
요산이 돼서 이게 배설이 되는 건데
이 과정에서 간이라든지 콩팥이라든지
이런 애들이 고생하는 거 아니냐라는 말이 나온 건데
이제 연구들은 체중당 2g per kg까지는
1년 이상 했던 연구들이 있어요
진짜 많이 먹는 거거든요
말도 안 되게 먹는 거예요
저 같은 사람이 먹어도
하루에 단백질 130g 먹어야 되는 거니까
끼니당 단백질을 거의 한 40g 50g 먹는 건데
일반인은 그렇게 못 먹어요
왜냐면
단백질은 포만감을 되게 많이 줘요
우리나라 사람들 게다가 탄수화물 섭취량이
자기 전체 에너지 섭취량이
한 70% 정도 높거든요
그리고 탄수화물 줄이면
기름진 게 더 올라오고 막 그래요
그런데 단백질을 조금 높여주면
탄수가 좀 줄어드는 효과가 있고
그래서 오히려 우리나라 많은 여성분들은
단백질 섭취량을 조금 늘려주시면
훨씬 체중 조절이 쉬워지는 게 있어요
그리고 음식 소음
이거는 뭐냐
푸드 노이즈에 대한 거예요
이거 생각보다 있는 분들이 많아요
이게 진짜 없는 사람은 모른데
내 지금 생리적 배고픔이랑 무관하게
발생한 음식에 대한 끊임없고 강박적이며
침투적인 생각
그냥 뭐 먹고 싶다는 생각이 계속 나는 거예요
제 환자분 중에 위 절제 수술을 했어요
그리고 살을 많이 뺐어요
한 2, 30kg 빠졌어요
2, 30kg 빠졌는데
자기 너무 고통스럽다고 찾아온 거예요
너무 과자를 먹고 싶은 갈망이 계속 있어가지고
근데 살찌는 건 그 사람은 너무 두려워하는 거예요
그래서 자기는 밥도 못 먹겠고
살찔까 봐
과자는 안 먹을 수가 없어가지고
과자만 먹는 음료수만 먹고
그래서 제가 덱 싸우면서 해봤어요
근육이 하나도 없어요
과자만 먹으니까
체지방은 40% 이렇게 되는데
근육이 하나도 없는 상태인데
약간 정신적인 문제인가?
그렇죠
자기 정신과도 다녔대요
정신과 다녔는데
뭐 맨날 똑같은 이야기하고 약하고 했는데
효과 하나도 없다고 답답해서 온 거예요
그분은 근데 체중은 안 뚱뚱해요
BMI로 보면 비만이 아니죠
근데 체지방으로 보면 비만이고
내장지방이 좀 있어요
근데 그러면 사실 위고비를 써볼 수 있는 거예요
그래서 그 분한테 말했어요
푸드 노이즈라는 거고
그게 그걸 조절하기 위해서
위고비를 써볼 수 있다라는 이야기하고 썼어요
그 분 진짜 좋았어요
그 다음에 왔는데 편해졌대요
과자를 안 먹어도 되니까
고기랑 밥을 먹을 수 있는 거예요
살찔 거에 대한 두려움이 떨어지니까
그래서 이게 되게 문제였거든요
이 푸드 노이즈 말하면
야 너는 왜 음식 생각밖에 안 하냐라고 하는데
뭐 어떻게 이게 생각이 나는데
그래서 이게 진짜 그 생리적 배고피랑 달라요
되게 강박적이고
되게 침투적이어서
그냥 밥을 배불리 먹었어
그럼 생각이 안 날 것 같아
밥을 배불리 먹었는데 그래도 나아요
어차피 이걸 다 먹게 돼
그러니까 두려워서 밥을 그냥 안 먹어버리는 거예요
제가 좀 그래요
다 먹고 음식 있으면 계속 먹어요
아무 생각 없이
그리고 아까 말씀하신 것처럼
내장지방이 많아요
내장지방은 BMI랑 상관없이
대사질환의 위험성을 올리긴 합니다
너무 염증이 늘어나고
약간 잘 부을 수 있고요
허허 이티영인가
이티영이고 과자를 좋아해요
허허 그래요?
아까 말씀하신 부분에 약간 약화판
아 그래요?
한번 나중에 봅시다
배 한번 만져볼게요
형은 이건 없나요?
이건 없잖아요
통제력 상실로 인한 죄책감의 수치심
전혀 없어요
그래요?
이것 때문에 너무 고통스러워요
근데 하여튼 이거 비해서
재밌는 거 되게 많이 해요
인폼 서베이라고 해가지고
한 550대상으로 음식 소음이 좀 줄어드는지 이거 봤어요
이게 한 62% 정도였었는데
16%로 거의 46%가 떨어진 거죠
너무 많이 떨어졌는데
네
그리고 이 푸드노이즈가 실제 내 삶에 부정적인 영향
그러니까 일할 때도 생각나서 미치겠대요
그러니까 간식을 옆에 놔두고 그냥 먹는대요
이거 안 먹으면 생각이 계속 나니까
일을 할 수가 없어서
그냥 먹는다
직장에서 막 간식통 만들어 놓은 사람들
좀 이런 확률이 높겠다
그렇죠 근데 그게 또 조건화돼요
항상 그 스트레스 받을 때 먹다 보면
그 스트레스 상황이 꼭 직장이 아니어도 먹고 싶은
그래서 그런 비율도 한 3분의 1 정도로 떨어지고
나의 그 정신 건강이 좋아졌다
이게 거의 60%였어요
이게 정신적인 문제가 크구나
그러니까 생각보다 비만이셨다가 좀 살이 빠지거나
실제 그 점 지금 비만이신 분들이 엄청 참고 있어요
그 끊임없는 충동 때문에
근데 그게 되게 삶의 질을 떨어뜨리거든요
그다음에 이제
등가교환이다, 부등가교환이다
왜냐면 이게 너무 좋잖아요
너무 좋아
여기 좋은 게 있을 리 없어
네 진짜 여러분 강철의 연금술사는 진짜 좋은 애니입니다
등가교환에 대한 어떤 그걸 우리한테 알려줬는데
이게 우리나라 진짜 문제긴 해요 지금
그 음식에 대한 선호도를 순간적으로 없애버리거든요
유고비 마운 자료가
그러면은 이게 진짜 무서워
음식에 대한 선호도가 없어요
갓 태어난 아이야
근데 갓 태어난 아이가
세상 모든 걸 다 먹어볼 수 있어
그럼 이 아이는 뭘 먹게 될까요 이제
맛있는 거
그쵸
우리를 둘러싸고 있는 식품환경이
햄
20년 전보다 지금 더 안 좋아졌거든요
햄 맛있으니까
이 정도로까지 자극점식이 덜 했어요
점점 많아지고 있고
광고도 훨씬 많아졌어요
마케팅 노출도 진짜 많아졌고
햄뿐만이 아니죠
과자, 액상과당 이것들의 조화 난리가 났잖아요
그리고 마케팅도 그냥 TV가 아니라
스마트폰으로 계속 접하게 되고
막 먹방도 하게 되고
맞아요
그래서 음식에 대한 선호도가 일시적으로 좀 없어졌다가
노출되는 음식들에 대해 그냥 쏠려가요
우리나라가 이거 연구하기 되게 좋은데
사람들이 어떻게 행태일을 보이는지
쏠려갑니다
그러면은 기본적으로 달달하고 기름진 음식에 대한 선호도가 점점 올라가요
다시
근데 또 여기서 기름진 음식에 대한 선호도가 내려가요
이건 속이 불편하니까
그러면은 뭐가 남냐
달달한 음식이랑 면유가 남아요
아 저예요 저
면을 좋아해요
마운 자료도 안 하시지 않나요
네
어허
그러니까 이렇게 됩니다
그러니까 이게 면 좋아하게 되고
속 편하고 국물 있는 거
네 이렇게 돼요
짜장 먹고 술술 넘어가는 거
네 이렇게 돼버려요
근데 이 과정 속에서 너무 전체 칼로리가 줄어드니까 살이 빠져요
그럼 아 나 약이 잘 듣는가 보다
나 진짜 금방 배부르다라는 이야기를 하면서
그럼 살이 빠지니까 잘 됐다 생각하는데
뇌생활 감찰하고 있는 거 아니에요
아 그래요 그럼 큰일 나요
내장지방이 계속 늘어나게 되고
이 약제를 끊었을 때
이 약제를 하고 있을 때도 내장지방이 많으니까 좀 안 좋죠
근데 약제를 끊었을 때
진짜 재앙이에요 재앙
왜냐면 근육 손실도 되게 많게 되고요
아 여러분 그거 아셔야 됩니다
이렇게 탄수화물 섭취를 엄청 늘려요
그러면 오히려 부종이 생길 수도 있거든요
네
근데 그럴 때 인바디를 하시면은
근육량을 많다고 평가할 수가 있어요
왜냐면 인바디의 기전이
근육은 물이 많고 지방은 뭐 기름이니까 당연히 물이 없죠
그러니까
근육을 인식하는구나
아 그쵸 물이 많으면 근육을 인식하는 거예요
그래서 탄수화물 많이 먹어서 인슐린도 많이 나와서
체내의 그 수분량이 늘어나면은
근육량이 유지되거나 늘었다라고 평가하는 경우들이 있어요
그래서 나 다이어트 잘 되고 있네라고 생각할 수가 있어요
아 좋은 건데
응
그리고 또 인바디 재밌는 게
인바디가 항상 덱사 검사보다
보통 체지방이 한 4% 정도 낮게 나와요
나 왜 그렇게 설정했는지 모르겠어
기분 좋게 하려고 그러나
모르겠어요
네 교정할 수 있을 것 같은데
보정 딱 넣으면 되니까 4% 더 붙여서
한 4% 정도 적게 나와요
전체적으로 높게 나온다면
네
그래서 저 막 그 검사했을 때도 선생님이
아 말도 안 된다고 더 높게 나와야 된다고
계속 막 저주하셨잖아요
와서 덱사 한번 찍어봐요 해드릴게요
왜 자꾸 저주를
좋게 나오면 좋은 건데 왜
아 좋게 나오면 좋죠
근데 우리가
나쁘게 나와야 되는데
아 예 우리가 제일 위험한 게
위험을 인지하지 못하면 위험하니까
이제 그거에 대한 이야기고요
그래서 육업이나 마훈자로는
이제 이런 굉장히 왜곡된 방향의 식욕 조절할 수 있고
그러면 진짜 자기 돈 써가지고
몸을 아프게 하는 게 돼요
근데 보통 이렇게 진짜 안 좋아지시는 분들
그냥 약만 받고 나왔어요 라는 분이 되게 많아요
좀 싸니까 뭐 10만, 10만 원 더 싸니까
이렇게 한 몇 달 하다가
이게 너무 이상하고 약을 이제 끊을 생각을 하니까
막 걱정이 본인도 되는 거예요
그래가지고 찾아오신 분이 되게 많아요
그래서 물어보면 아까 제가 말한 대로
3개월 치 약을 한 번에 사면 할인해 준다
너 뭔 소리인지 모르겠어
용량이 어떻게 될 줄 알고
그러니까 이게 아셔야 돼요
질 높은 감량이 있고 질 낮은 감량이 있어요
어차피 여러분 이거 되게 비싼 약이에요
여러분이 아무리 싸게 사도 되게 비싼 약인데
이 비싼 약을 할 거면요
진짜 질 높은 감량을 해야 돼요
근데 그러면은 근육이 진짜 거의 안 빠져요
제가 어제도 덱사 검사 2명 정도 팔로우 업 했는데
팔, 다리 근육 늘었어요 한 명은
지방은 거의 한 6, 7kg 빠졌는데
보통 근육이 거의 안 빠져요
근육이 적었던 여성은 그게 돼요
그러니까 체중은 한 6, 7kg밖에 안 빠진 거예요
그런데 만약에 근육까지 같이 빠졌다
그럼 뭐 10kg 넘게 빠졌겠죠
그럼 이 10kg 빠진 게 좋은 거냐
6, 7kg 빠진 게 좋은 거냐
당연히 6, 7kg 빠진 게 좋은 거죠
근육이 지켰으니까
그리고 근육을 지키면서 뺐기 때문에
이 사람이 계속 빠질 수 있어요
감량이 계속 돼요
근데 근 손실이 되면서 빠지면
처음에는 그 수분이 같이 날아가니까
빠지는 것처럼 보이지만 금방 이제 정체기가 와요
근육이 있어야 또 이게 계속 에너지를 쓰잖아요
어차피 비싼 약인데
이거 내가 진짜 몇만 원 싸게 하겠다고
몇 달 동안 자기 몸 진짜 망가뜨리는 거거든요
그렇게 할 거면은
저는 굳이 위고비 마원절 할 필요 없이
식욕 억제 먹는 게 낫다고 생각해요
가격적으로 생각을 했을 때
왜냐면 그런 식으로 쓰니까
그렇게 쓸 거면 더 비싸서 하이호환이 되고
그 좋은 약은
전반적으로 몸에 부담 없게 할 수 있는 방법이 있으니까
그렇게 사용하는 게 좋은 거 같다
몸에 부담은 없을까요?
아직 뭐 결과가 없죠?
몸에 부담이 있냐라는 이야기 진짜 많이 하시는데
췌장 약이 진짜 많이 해요
췌장...
췌장이 안 좋아지는 거 아니냐
이거는 이야기 드릴 수 있을 것 같아요
제대로 쓰면요
췌장의 기능은 압도적으로 보존돼요
당뇨병 환자들 가지고 해보면 우리가 알게 되는데
이 마원절호나 위고비를 쓴 사람
그러니까 GLP-1을 쓴 사람이랑
다른 약자를 쓴 사람
추후에 인슐린 투약을 할 확률
GLP-1을 쓴 사람이 더 낮아요
왜냐면 췌장이 진짜 고통스러워 하는 건요
혈당이 높아지면 진짜 고통스러워요
그리고 혈중 지방이 높아져도 췌장은 고통스러워요
근데 비만인 분들은 보통 그 상태인 거예요
식후 혈당 되게 높고
내장 지방에서 계속 지방이 줄줄 흘러나와가지고
지방독성을 일으키고
그래서 췌장은 그냥 그 상태로 고통받고 있는 거예요
오히려 이런 위고비나 마원절호를 쓰면
고혈당도 확 줄어들게 되고
계속해서 막 흩뿌려지게 날아가는
이소성 지방침착이라는 게 줄어들어요
그래서 췌장은 오히려 세이브가 되고
췌장염 같은 경우 있죠 여러분
췌장염
췌장염이 늘어난다고 처음 좀 생각했어요
왜냐면 기존적으로 GLP-1을 쓰면
인슐린 분비가 더 촉진하고
아밀라아제, 리파아제라는
췌장에서 나오는 소화효소 있거든요
이것도 약간 분비세포에 수용체가 있어서
약간 기저수준이 높아지는 이런 게 있어가지고
좀 췌장염이 위험하지 않을까 생각을 했었는데
실제 저희가 막 연구를 해보니까
이게 오히려 감소시켜주는 데이터 코어트로 나오는 거예요
심지어 올해 나온 거는 데이터가 너무 좋게 나왔어
췌장염이 있었던 사람에게 약제를 썼어요
GLP-1 쓴 사람 안 쓴 사람이 있으니까
GLP-1을 썼던 사람이
반복되는 췌장염의 확률이
거의 한 3분의 1까지 낮아지는 것도 있었어요
근데 보통 그래서 거의 뉴트럴하거나
조금 보호에 대한 효과가 있지 않을까라는 게
약간 중론이고
근데 그 이유가 뭐냐
중성지방혈증이 높은 거
그리고 술 먹는 게 훨씬 안 좋아요
근데 이제 췌장염을 올리는 기저는 그래서
보통 담석증이라고 생각을 하고 있어요
돌이 생겨가지고 그게 막아서 췌장염을 생기는 거
이거는 이제 가능하니까
담석증을 좀 주의하자 나오는 거고
췌장암
췌장암도 엄청 말이 많았죠
근데
췌장암도 우리가 봐보니까
오히려 리스크가 감소하는 데이터들이 많이 나와요
그리고 췌장염이 있었던 환자
액에 썼을 때
췌장염이 반복되면
췌장암의 확률이 올라가거든요
췌장염이 있었던 사람도
췌장암이 생기는 확률이 좀 낮아지는
이런 것들을 보여요
그러니까 그냥 고혈당
그리고 간식을 계속 먹는 것
이런 것들이 생각보다
췌장암을 되게 괴롭히는 거예요
뭐 얼마나 괴롭히면 좀 설명을 드릴까요
네
뭐 콜라 예를 들어
좋아 콜라 콜라 합시다
이 침착맨 님의 피에
당이 한 5g 녹아있어요 5g
한 5리터 들었다고 합시다 피가
네
이 5리터의 피에 당이 5g 이만큼 들어있는 거예요
이만큼으로 침착맨 님의 피에 혈당을 유지하고 있는 건데
콜라 뚱캔 한 40g 정도 돼요
네
과당이긴 한데 액상과당
그럼 그게 들어오는데 얘는 액상형이잖아요
인류가 이전에 존재하지 않았던 방식의 속도로 혈당이 올라요
침착맨 님이 췌장이 없다
그럼 혈당이 막 오류빼게 될 거예요 한 번에
몇 배가 들어왔으니까
근데 그렇게 안 되죠
췌장이 일을 해서
그쵸
근데 우리가 사실
일이
제일 힘든 게 뭐냐
갑자기 나한테 딱 가만히 아무것도 안 하고 있었는데
너 지금 당장 그림 100개 그려 이러면서 휘추릴 때 생각해보세요
스트레스 엄청 받겠죠
스트레스 받아요
이거 진짜 말도 안 되는 일을
췌장은 나 가만히 있었는데
이게 뭐야 이러면서
엄청나게 많은 인슐린을 만들어야 돼요 췌장이
짧은 시간 안에
짧은 시간 안에 엄청나게 많은 인슐린을 만들어야 되는데
사실 이거 단백질이에요
인슐린 여러분 만만한 거 아닙니다
그래서 여기에 엄청 큰 스트레스가 걸려요
갑자기 일이 확 몰리니까
이 과정이
안에서 그 산화 스트레스를 만들고
소포체 스트레스를 만들고 해가지고
췌장이 기능이 떨어지는 게 돼요
그래서 이렇게 갑자기 혈당이 올라가는 게
진짜 췌장한테는 너무 고통스럽다라는 거고
췌장이 없으면요
기절합니다
콜라 한 잔 마셨을 때
혈당이 막 백백 돼가지고
그럼 저 옛날에 막 콜라
치킨 먹을 때
제로도 아니고
1.2리터 오나
그러면 한 200ml 남기고 먹어서
한 1리터 먹었거든요
한 번 먹을 때
대단하다
그럼 췌장 엄청 일했네요
욕하면서 일했겠죠
근데 그거는 간도 고생이에요
이제 이런 측면에서
등가 교환, 부등가 교환
이야기가 있는데
사실 약을 잘 쓰면
진짜 저는 약간 부등가 교환일 정도로
이득이 많긴 해요
잘 쓰면 많은데
약을 잘 못 쓴다
그러면 실제 담석증 같은 게
꽤 많이 올라가요
그래서 우리나라도
여러 가지 이유가 있겠죠
지난 10년 사이에
이 담석증으로 인해서 수술 받는 사람이
거의 2배 늘었어요
그런데 그게 3, 40대 젊은 사람이 많이 늘었대요
그러니까 GLP-1에 영향이 좀 있는 거 같아요
아무리 봐도
그리고 해외에서 실명되는 사람들이
있었어요
이 실명이 되는 게
어떤 센터는 6배, 7배 위험도가 증가하고요
어떤 센터는 별로 안 올라가고
그래서 이거를 좀 분석할 때
어떻게 생각을 하냐면
어떤 클리닉마다
이 환자한테 약을 준 다음에
해주는 정도가 다를 거 아니에요
거기에 있어서
어떤 수분 섭취라든지
이런 영양에 대한 가이딩이 잘 된 곳은
아마 좀 적게 생기고
이런 게 잘 안 된 곳은
이런 리스크가 이렇게 훨씬 더 많이 올라가고
약제 용량 조절도 있어서
탈수가 될 정도로 약을 좀 빠르게 올리는 그런 것들
그래서 가끔 이게 약 쓰면서
나 살 많이 빠졌다고 좋아하시는 분들이 있거든요
한 달에 10kg 빠졌어
진짜 위험한 겁니다
오히려 너무 극단적으로 이렇게 되면
실명과 근감소와 담석증의 리스크가 다 올라간 거예요
그래서 감량 속도는 천천히 해야 되는 거다
그리고 충분한 수분 섭취 이런 걸 계속 감시해야 된다
왜냐면 음식만 적게 먹는 게 아니라
물도 좀 섭취가 줄어들 수가 있다
이건 약간 좀 off the record이긴 한데
실제 약간 좀 급사 같은 것도 있냐면
이게 전해질 불균형이니까
식욕이 줄어든다는 게 생존의 필수적인 부분을
우리 뇌가 인지하지 못하게 되는 거거든요
그래서 진짜 필요한 거를 안 먹을 수도 있어요
그래서 요새는 진짜 어떤 클리닉은
이 glp-1을 쓰면서 약제를 6개인가를 같이 주더라고요
보니까 안에 막 인유들이랑 같이 들어있어요
왜냐면 이 사람이 glp-1을 맞고
어느 정도로 식욕이 억제되고
어느 정도로 먹게 될지 모르잖아요
근데 일단 묶어서 주니까
그쵸 그리고 1900년대 초에 하던 거거든요
그래서 적어도 감량이 안 돼서
이 뇌가 줄어들지 않으니까
어떤 특정 약제를 좀 결합하거나
부작용을 낮추기 위한 약제를 더 할 수도 있어요
상황을 보고 해야 되는데
상황을 보고 해야죠
처음 받았는데 이거를 같이 주면은
뭐 어쩌자는 거야
이 환자가 어떻게 반응할 줄 알고
진짜 위험합니다
애시당초 그렇게 된 연구가 하나도 없어요
처음에는 조심스럽게 접근을 해서
맞춰가면서 하는 게 제일 베스트고
그렇기 때문에 의사의 지도 하에 해야 되니까
옆에 붙어서 조언을 받으면서 해야 되고
그냥 하면 모르니까
그렇게 하면 여러분들은 부등가로
교환으로 좋은 이득을 취할 수 있다라는 거고
그렇게 하지 않으면 등가 교환으로 팔 잃을 수 있습니다
사실은 그게 만약에 의사의 지도가 필요 없다면
그냥 약국에서 팔았겠죠
그쵸 맞아 맞는 말이네요
그게 의사를 꼭 통해가지고 약을 구해야 된다는 거는
그만큼 좀 세심한 지도나
사용 방법이 좀 필요하니까 그런 거겠죠
맞습니다
알겠습니다
약으로 살찌지 않는 몸이 될 수 있을까
제가 이 책에 약간 그래서 적어놓은 게 좀 있어요
요거
이걸 갖고 다니는 사람 처음 봤어 이거
네 이거 한
수고용 가짜 책
이거 여러분 진짜
실제로 이 정도 크기인데
진짜 이거 제가 썼지만 읽을만 합니다
왜냐면은 이런 게 좀 필요하지 않을까라는 생각을 하고 제가 썼거든요
그래서 내가 어떻게 살을 빼야 될지 모르겠다
혹은 내가 점점 살이 찌는데
이거 왜 찌는지 모르겠다
혹시라도 내가 감량을 생각하신다면은
뭐 약재를 사용하든 사용하지 않든
한번 읽어보시면은
이런 방향으로 가는 게 나한테 장기적으로 안전하고 좋겠다라는 거를
객관적으로 이해하실 수 있게 제가 옆에 앉아서 이렇게 말하는 것처럼 썼거든요
이거 진짜 제가 추천한 이유가
저희 와이프
저희 와이프가 제 말 듣겠어요
혜리씨
혜리는 제 말 진짜 안 들어요
저 와이프가 가끔씩 침대에 누워가지고 과자를 한 번씩 먹는 거예요
먹을 수 있잖아요 한 번씩
아 먹을 수 있죠
근데 자꾸 먹으니까 얘가 나한테 거슬리는 거야
빈도가 어느 정도인데
잘 모르겠네
어 그래가지고 몇 번 말했죠
화를 벌컥 내는 거예요
이게 나의 낙인데
너 때문에 기분 내가
잡혔어
모르고 먹었으면 그냥 상관없는데 어차피
어차피 먹을 건데 기분 잡히고 먹잖아
네 그리고 이제 저희 와이프도 약간 좀 근육이 좀 적은 여성
과일 같은 걸 잘 안 먹어요
수용성 식이섬유 좀 부족한데
그래서 근데 제가 이제 말해봤자 안 들으니까
말이 안 통해 말이 길어지려면 오빠 이렇게 말이 긴가 막 이런 소리를 해버리니까
말을 좀 많이 하긴 해
투머치 토크 하긴 해
맞아요 좀 질린 거 같은데
하여튼
근데 이게 이걸 알아야 돼 시청자분들은
이 단편적인 거 보면은 어 혜리님이에요 이렇게 과민반응이 하는데
이거를 꾸준히 이게 상황이 있었을 거 아니에요
네 맞아요
그러니까 이게 과민반응이 나올 수도 있다니까
이거 우리가 자세히 안 보면 몰라
맞아 맞아 인정합니다
근데 이제 난 그래서 그걸 여쭤본 거예요
과자를 일주일에 몇 번 정도 드시는지
그렇게 많이는 안 먹어 꼭 가끔씩
그니까 가끔 먹는데 계속 이러니까 그런 거 같아
예를 들어 맨날 먹어 그러면은 할 말이 없어
근데 본인이 나름 이제 참는다고 해가지고
한 일주일에 두 번 한 번 이렇게 딱 먹는데
올 때마다 와가지고
야 그 과자 과자 좀 그만 먹어라
과자 먹으면 너 어떻게 되는 줄 알아
너 그냥 낙오되는 거야
뭘 낙오해요
야
그렇게 얘기 안 하지 내가
너 몸 다 망가져 너 폐인 되고 싶어
아니 그냥
야 그거 누워가지고 먹으면 더 안 좋은 거 알지
야 그럼 자세라도 똑바로 하던가
아이씨 나가
진짜
들어갈게요
그러면 막 아이스크림 사오라고 그래 나한테
아 그러니까
나한테 막 갑자기 아이스크림 사오라고 그래
그러니까
그랬는데 이 책 읽더니 아침에 단백질 쉐이크도 챙겨 먹고요
본인도 이제 막 주변 사람들한테 약간 좀 저처럼 잔소리도 하고
아 효과가 있네요 그러면
읽으니까 좀 그래도 뭔가
어 이게 좀 마음이 동하는 게 있구나 라고 해서 이야기를 해봤어요
했더니 뭐
왜 그렇게 이야기했는지 알 것 같다
아주 작은 거지만 이런 걸 좀 바꾸는 게 의미가 있을 것 같다
라는 이야기를 좀 해가지고
어 진짜 의미가 있구나 라고 해서
그 뒤로는 제가 이제 잔소리 안 하고 있어요
약간 제가 왜 지금 이 오프닝이라고 하냐면은
장기적으로 로고도즈로 썼을 때
노화의 속도를 좀 조절해줄 수 있는
이런 효과가 좀 기대되는 게 있어요
왜냐면 이제 우리가 2013년까지 해가지고
노화를 시키게 하는 몇 가지의 요소들을 꽤 많이 알아냈거든요
근데 그것들에 이 GL 표현이 작용하는 게
너무 많은 거예요
그래서 다른 약자들과 어떤 시너지 결합으로
이 노화의 어떤 속도를 낮추는 것도 해볼 수 있지 않을까
이거를 지금 하고 있습니다
사실 다이어트 뭐 위고비 마원자로 지금 너무 이제 보편화됐지만
그 전 생각하면은 사실 말도 안 되는 약이거든요
그쵸 말도 안 되죠
그냥 무조건 맞으면 살이 빠진다
그런 것처럼 맞으면 노화가 10분의 1로 준다
이런 약 나올 수 있잖아요
그럴 수 있죠
지금 실제로 그 메포민
메포민이 아마 약하긴 할 거예요
테임 연구라고
그 약을 진짜 실제 인간에서 좀 늦출 수 있는지
왜냐면 쥐는 우리가 오래 살게 한 게 너무 많아요
쥐는 수명을 한 10에서 15%씩 늘리는 약들이 너무 많아서
메포민은 인체 연구 지금 진행 중입니다
결과가 곧 나올 거예요
쥐는 장수합니다 요새
야 그러면은 나이 먹어버린 사람은 좀 아쉽겠다
그럴 수도 있죠
돌이키는 것도 나올 수도 있잖아요
아 근데 이게 돌이키는 거는
새로운 세포로 그냥 다 도배
지금까지 나온 거는 그러니까 가속 노화한 사람들
실제 약간 젊어지기도 하는데
지금 잘 하고 있는 사람들은 슬로잉하는
약간 이런 거긴 해요
근데 이미 내가 막 인생 진짜 엉망으로 살았다
그러면은
원래 템포로 돌려주는 거야?
진짜 오히려 약간 젊어지기도 해요
실제로 그래서 어떤 사람들은 특히 좋냐 라고 하면
담배 피는 사람이랑 내장지방 많은 이런 사람들
몸을 가혹하게 썼던 사람
그런 사람들이 GLP-1에 대해서 좋은 데이터가 많고
노화도 이게 사람에 너무나 큰 관심사고
건강에 직결되는 문제이기 때문에
연구는 엄청나게 되고 있을 거 아니에요
지금 장난 아니에요
근데 이게 내분비 쪽에서 관심 있는 분야가 되게 많아요
아까 제가 말했던
그리고 이제 염증, 회복 이 세 개의 축에서 보통 이루어지는데
대사에서 나오는 게 인슐린 저항성이라든지
뭐 이런 게 나오는 거고
염증에서도 이제 면역세포들의 어떤 활성도라든지
만성염증 이런 것들이 막 다 나오는데
이게 다 저희 내분비에서 관심 있는 것들이고
저희가 보니까 당뇨병 환자들이 빨리 늙었던 거예요
옛날부터 맨날 보니까
그리고 내장지방 많은 사람들이 빨리 늙고
그래서 이게 왜 이런 걸로 하다 보니까
노화의 어떤 요소들을 이제 꽤 많이 알아요 진짜
그래서
정말 재밌는 연구들이 진짜 꽤 많이 나왔고요
제가 언제 들어온 것도 한번 좀 정리해가지고
노화에 관련돼서
네 진짜 재밌어요
다음엔 또 노화에 대한 특강도 하면 좋을 거 같아요
네
심창민 님도 오래 살아야 되고
보시는 침투부 님도 다 오래 살아야 되니까
그러면 선생님이 봤을 때는
노화 이거 정복 얼마 안 남았다?
아 그거 정복 얼마 안 남았...
선생님 그냥 개인적인 생각
개인적인 생각
이건 뭐 공신력 없이 그냥 개인이 생각했을 때
저는 10년 내에 한번 올 거 같아요
아 뭔가 유의미한 뭐 변화가
이게 제가 괜히 이런 말 하는 건 아니고
노화를 구성하는 여러 요소들에 대해서
지난 한 10년? 20년간?
꽤 많이 나왔거든요
근데 사람이 뭐예요
요소들 이유들을
메커니즘을 알면
여기에 해당하는 것들을
굉장히 많이 하고 싶잖아요
근데 지금 메커니즘을 많이 알잖아요
그쵸
근데 예전에 했던 것들중에 되게 이상한 게 많았던 이유가
이거 하면 그럴싸하겠다라는 게 되게 많았어요
그래서 메커니즘에 대한 연구와
이거 그럴싸하겠다
상상으로 했던 게 되게 많이 나왔는데
이제 이 메커니즘에 대한 건 꽤 많이 알게 되면서
이 메커니즘에 맞는 실제 조치를 했을 때
그때 이거의 결과가 어떻게 나오는지 앞으로 나올 게 되게 많아요.
그게 앞으로 5년간 되게 많이 나올 거예요.
AI도 있고.
실제 어떻게 됐는지를.
그러면 각 메커니즘에도 실제 된 걸 알았어.
그럼 이제 그다음 뭐냐.
결국 멀티 팩토리아를 할 거예요.
멀티 팩토리라는 게 뭐냐.
당뇨병이든 고혈압이든 요소들이 사실 다양하단 말이에요.
그럼 단일 약재를 쓰는 것보다
이 요소들의 각각 작용한 약재들 복합해서 훨씬 좋은 효과가 나왔어요.
그러면 한 5년 정도 뒤에는
이 요소들을 조합해서 어떻게 개인 맞춤을 할지
이게 아주 심플하게 나올 거예요.
그러면 한 10년 정도 되면 저는 진짜 많이 달라지지 않을까요?
그러면 잘 됐다.
제가 전문님 60살 환갑잔치 할 때
제가 딱 그 약을 사와서 선물로 딱 드리면 돼요.
10년 뒤잖아요.
지금 50살이니까 딱 환갑잔치 때
딱 그 한복 입고 밝게 춤출 때
제가 딱 상자에 넣어서 싹 넣어드리면
얼마나 반가우시겠어요.
좋아하시겠죠.
그때 뀨리 고등학생일 텐데
아버지 환갑잔치 때 딱 받아가지고
오래 살아야죠.
얼마나 좋아.
진짜.
진짜 좋은 세상이 되고 있어요.
비만약도 이렇게 나올 줄 몰랐어요.
저 레전드 때문에.
오늘 선생님하고 마운자로 위고비
우리가 진짜 평소에 너무 관심 있었죠.
그리고 맞는 분들도 너무 많으시고
근데 이제 너무 친숙하지만
요거의 정체에 대해서 좀 궁금하고
어떻게 사용해야지 옳게 사용하는지
좀 많이 궁금했는데
선생님 모시고 얘기 들어보니까
많이 좀 도움이 됐던 것 같습니다.
감사합니다.
포인트는 아까도 설명드렸지만
의사의 지도 하에 하는 게 가장 좋다는 거.
그렇죠.
너무 이제 약만 딱 받아가지고
왜냐면 간편하거든.
그러니까 간편하다고 해서 그냥 이렇게 하는 것보다는
용량이나 이런 거는 상담을 통해서
경과도 좀 지켜보고 하는 거를 좀 추천드리고
마운자로 위고비 뭐 약간 등가교환이라고 생각해가지고
아 이거를 내가 너무 혁신적으로 빼버리면
몸의 다른 쪽에서 이상이 있지 않을까 하는데
오히려 좀 더 건강해지는
진짜 좀 되게 획기적인 약이라고 하니까
좋게 쓸 수 있다면은
건강하게 살을 뺄 수 있다.
이렇게 좀 말씀을 드릴 수 있을 것 같습니다.
그리고 뭐 제가 계속 얘기를 들어보니까
의사 선생님들 세미나가 있고
제가 굉장히 좀 약간 의사 선생님들 된 것 같은 느낌도 들고
실제로 의사 대상에서도 제가 하는 강의를 많이 해가지고
근데 좀 재밌는 이야기를 해드리고 싶어서
알겠습니다.
자 그러면은 여러분들은 어떤 약이 나왔으면 좋겠는지
한번 또 댓글을 좀 달아주시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
오늘 강의는 여기서 마치도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.